2024 is wrapping up its first month
Donald Trump has been nominated for the
Nobel Peace Prize for his historic work
with the Abraham Accords Joe Biden has
announced he's made his decision which
we believe may be to strike Iran
directly their Naval forces not their uh
country which could sparkk World War II
many fear and benjiro is the world's
number one rapper so uh we're getting
off to a to a bang here and I'm really
excited for all of it but uh those are
the big stories we also have some other
crazy stories Ronda santz is calling out
ilhan Omar after a video surface where
she's talking about essentially serving
Somalia and not the United States which
brings up a lot of criticism from people
on social media about Israel so this
will be a fun topic of conversation yeah
you know we're going with this but uh uh
we definitely got to talk about what's
going on with war that's the big story
Joe Biden Donald Trump and all that
stuff before we do my friends head over
to facts with ben.com that's
fswi ben.com Tom McDonald and Ben
Shapiro have released a song last week
it will be tracked by the ratings
agencies and Bill Bor will determine
based on these numbers if the song will
chart I believe based on the numbers I
have been able to see based on how many
streams they got
and some other metrics it looks like not
only has Ben Chapo cracked the number
one song worldwide on iTunes it is
extremely likely that Tom McDonald and
Ben shipiro will hit the Hot 100 which
is the top 100 songs for the week which
is a tremendous
feat we are not being sponsored in any
way by them I'm friends with these guys
I want to see them succeed and more
importantly sorry Tom sorry Ben I care
more about giving a middle finger to
billboard to the ratings agencies to the
corporate press and The Gatekeepers who
want to keep everybody out especially
Independent Artists whatever your
politics may be so we are shouting them
out all week next week Tuesday the
charts should drop and we will see where
they're at I think I got to be honest
there is a decent possibility that they
get close to number one if everyone
bought the song at facts withth ben.com
it's possible Ben P Shapiro could be the
number one Hot 100 song with Tom
McDonald and Tom deserves it for sure
because Tom's a hardworking really
talented guy and I know he brought on
Ben just to have a laugh into but I'm
really hoping that uh we can muster up
as much as possible I already bought the
song I hope everybody else does uh buy
the song on Amazon the link is in the in
the description below to support their
work and uh hey look when I said we want
to challenge the The Gatekeepers we want
to build culture it's not just about the
work that we do it's not just about the
songs we're making Tom McDonald is an
awesome dude he does hard work he's got
a great message you should really check
out the song if you haven't yet because
Ben's in it and you know it's going to
be about it's calling out the woke it's
calling about the constantly offended
people and the hypocrisy so so do that
and uh shout out to Ben Shapiro who
officially changed his profile to read
world's number one
rapper I guess you could argue Ben you
know Tom McDonald is but you're both
sitting there together so respect also
head over to cast brew.com buy our
coffee when you buy our coffee or
supporting the show and appalachin
nights of course is the best coffee you
will ever have all of our coffee is very
delicious but uh we we we're struggling
to keep appalachin kns in stock because
once people buy it they try to buy it
all out now we're we're out of ground
and man we're getting restocked
everybody we're getting restocked also
head over to timcast.net
joining us tonight to talk about this
and everything else finally is scks
hexenhammer AKA tar Warwick thank you
I'm uh glad to be here grab that mic oh
yeah yeah sorry I'm I'm not used to this
particular kind of setup uh who are you
what do you do uh I'm a YouTuber content
creator and editor and author and
Gardener Gardener yeah right uh you've
been around for for a long time I don't
really know how to describe your your
politics independent anti-establishment
classically liberal I'd say classically
Liberal classically Liberal well that's
enough we're we're glad to have you
everyone's really excited there are
spoons littering our chat because for
those that don't know uh that's your
like your emoji I guess people post
spoons yes uh thank you to all the
clankers out there right on this should
be a fun conversation thanks for hanging
out we got cter Banks hanging out sup
guys sticks great to have you I'm a huge
fan been watching your stuff for a while
too um so I'm also familiar with the
spoon thing um a music guy uh for
timcast trash house record um and got
Hannah Clair hanging out as well hey I'm
Hannah Clair bmla I'm a writer for
scanner news that's cnr.com I'm really
happy to be part of that team uh Tim is
specifically calling me out because I
had no idea what the spoon thing was
it's she thought it was Sheamus yeah I
just assume it's Sheamus ruining my life
forever anyways uh Serge is here yes I
am here and uh I'm excited for the show
today especially the after questions so
uh let's so basically what happens is
you know Sheamus is staying at my house
and you know my my girlfriend notices
that the spoon the the the the utensil
drawers the spoons are gone and she's
like where are our spoons going and I'm
like it's probably Sheamus well Sheamus
would make a cup of coffee then go
downstairs and then put it in the sink
and he was transporting our spoons one
at a time and then uh I was like oh hey
Sheamus you have spoons down there and
he's like yeah and then he brings them
up it's no big deal it was like five
spoons and then Sheamus just goes
there's an Irish man in my basement who
keeps stealing my spoons and we were
like we're rolling with that and that's
what we Meed in anyway let's jump into
the news now that everyone understands
the context of jamus stealing spoons uh
from the post millennial Trump nominated
for Nobel Peace Prize by GOP rep for
historic Abraham Accords it's not the
first time Trump has been nominated for
the prestigious award and I do want to
say as we we we get going it doesn't
mean all that much it's a nice thing
someone can say but I do think it
matters because Donald Trump no new Wars
Donald Trump setting timelines for
bringing our troops out of these
countries trying to get our troops out
of Syria negotiating with some of the
worst people in the world and of course
the Abraham Accord if anyone deserves
this it's him however Barack Obama did
end up winning one a long time ago
despite doing nothing the story is on
Tuesday rep Claudia Tenny announced that
she had nominated Donald Trump for a
Nobel Peace Prize citing his
groundbreaking efforts to Foster peace
and cooperation between Israel Bahrain
Morocco Sudan and the United Arab
Emirates via the highly praised Abraham
Accords Tenny compared the former
president's work to that of the 1978
peace agreement between Israel and Saudi
Arabia and the 1994 Oslo Accords both of
which were were recognized and rewarded
by the Nobel Peace Prize committee
Donald Trump was instrumental in
facilitating the First new peace
agreements in the Middle East in almost
30 years for decades bureaucrats foreign
policy professionals and international
organizations insisted that additional
Middle East peace agreements were
impossible without a resolution to the
Israeli Palestinian conflict president
Trump proved that to be false and she
goes on to praise uh the former
president and the work that he did and
it's kind of sad I got to tell you right
now we are looking at Joe Biden
who has announced his decision that he
has a decision not that he's we don't
know exactly what he's going to do but
the speculation is that he will strike
the Iranian Navy directly which would
essentially be a unilateral declaration
of war and could trigger Iran to
officially and formally declare war and
Congress would not have declared that so
that's a disaster but it's also sad when
you realize Donald Trump was President
we had no new Wars he leaves
everything's falling apart the Abraham
Accords are basically gone
Israel Gaza all that conflict Ukraine
China has deployed warships surrounding
Taiwan Venezuela is going to make move
on Guyana World War III may be on the
horizon houthi Rebels are shutting down
one of the most prominent shipping lanes
in the world to the Red Sea and none of
this is happening when Trump's president
maybe because why Trump threatened to
Nuke people is that it well you've also
got Eco was popping off there in West
Africa as well you've got ecoas and the
ecoas alliance with Nigeria and those
other countries uh they were threatening
with uh uh what is it Burkina Faso Mali
and I can't remember the Third Country
there oh wow that could pop off as well
well I realize it was that bad lost all
hope it's everywhere well hopefully you
know this is the fourth time's the charm
Trump finally gets Nobel Peace Prize I
mean way back in the day Australia like
a coalition of Australian um officials
nominated him because they said under
the Trump doctor and he's pulled America
out of endless Wars and that's been good
for the entire world and now we have Joe
Biden who's like but I like War I think
this might be fun uh the other thing is
that the Nobel Peace Prize decision
comes out in October which would be the
most hilarious October Twist of all time
that they actually are like you know
we're really scared of World War III so
we're GNA give it to Trump the elections
3 weeks later but what are the odds like
close to zero that they actually give it
to him I wonder if you can actually
ruining my
dreams I wonder if you can actually make
bets on that cuz apparently everyone's
going to get mad at me for bringing this
up but you can make bets on whether or
not Travis Kelsey will propose to Taylor
Swift like they're actually offering
that on Sports books or something like
this so anyway we will not we will not
we will not get into that subject we'll
go back to talking about war and
conflict and the uh the Peace Prize good
look I'm I'm sorry I got to tell you
guys the it's all fake everything's fake
the world's fake I just I just don't
believe anything's real anymore
everything's conspiracy like Truman Show
fake or what kind of fake you talking
because Barack Obama won the Nobel Peace
Prize and he did nothing like come on I
don't believe it's a real thing well he
did he he became president while being
you know of
color it's pretty
big brought peace to the world and
everyone sang Kum Baya and uh there were
love beads in meditation you remember
how great those years were you know I he
did you know this actually this is
actually funny he's the um how do I say
this he is the um he holds the record
for most children killed by a Nobel
Peace Prize winner what an honor a
distinguish gentlem I don't know that
that is actually true but it's a meme
it's like Barack Obama holds the most
the record for most children killed by a
Nobel Peace Prize winner and uh I think
that's probably true because like I
don't know I have to pull up a list of
all the other Nobel Prize winners but uh
he he blew up a lot of them you know
that was that was his thing he was
unless unless Stalin won a Nobel Peace
Prize or something right that's true I
mean Hitler was on the cover of Time
Magazine he was person of the year you
know and then well so was Obama
what are you suggesting one
substantially worse than the other but
Obama was pretty bad yeah I don't know
man and then the dude that he uh that uh
he mentored Joe he's uh somehow managed
to do even worse I have I have to
imagine we we we've been speculating
this since Joe Biden got the presidency
I don't want to say got elected got the
presidency uh that he's basically just
like this ragd doll they threw in the
room so that they can do all of the bad
things they want to do and that and make
him the Pariah basically so they're
thinking like okay we need to go War
here here here here and here whoever we
put in whoever does this it's going to
destroy them ah Joe Biden he's he's
basically dead anyway right he's got
like he's past the average life
expectancy of the US male he's got
plates in his brain what does he care
we'll tell him will'll pardon his son or
something they did just assume he'd be
in incredibly submissive right they did
just say he'll he'll listen to us and
he'll follow what we want which I think
is sort of the problem right now I think
they actually did want him to be a
one-term president and he is kicking and
screaming he and Jill do not want to
leave the White House I don't know I
can't believe that I think it's kind of
like his ego rubs UPS against their
agenda like they want him gone they want
to do their own like neocon neolib thing
but he's still like that you know long
ago he was a fiery dude if you look at
him when he was in the Senate he was
rather forceful he's got a big ego he
talks about wrapping a chain around corn
Pop's head and weird stuff like that Ry
I was a bad back in the 1960s let me
tell no he said Corn Pop was the bad
dude corop but I got to be honest when I
hear that story about how you know Corn
Pop was threatening him I'm willing to
like you he he Joe Biden said I'm
sitting in the pool and the kids are
rubbing my legs and got hairy legs and
I'm just like corn poop probably saw Joe
Biden doing some weird stuff with kids
and was like yo we're GNA stop you and
that's when Joe pulled out a chain and
like banged it on the ground right but
rain barrel got it Rusty that's right be
interesting to see like what so many
details from corn poop's point of view
what happened yeah why can we never find
corn poop that's a big question is it
would be very very politician of him to
take this story where potentially
someone was like hey leave those kids
alone and he's like and it turns out I
scared that that guy off look it was it
works in my favor or or it turns out
that Corn Pop is black and got racially
profiled no he was no I'm pretty sure
corn Pop's black dude oh God yeah yeah
that's that that was that's not even a
surprise yeah and then someone made an
animation of how he was talking about
the kids rub his legs like dude the guy
he you know his story is that Corn Pop
wasn't wearing what his his his bathing
cap or something like that something
like that he called him yeah he called
him I don't I thought he he dived off
the board the wrong way if I remember
correctly or he was running or something
yeah I don't know I think all I know is
his story is total BS like the reality
is is probably there is no corn poop I
didn't think there was but I almost wish
it was real me too because that would be
just the best thing ever if it was if if
cornpop was a real dude i' imagine he
was like a good guy who was like
watching Joe Biden creep on kids right
and he was a leader of a bunch of he ran
a bunch of bad dudes and his daughter
was at the pool that day Bad Dudes pop
saw churchgoing young men who didn't
like watching Joe Biden like grope
little girls or something is that is
that like why is this guy a lifeguard he
shouldn't be here yeah want have G I
mean but to your point I don't know if
this has to do with war or anything but
you know I was going to say funny anyway
yeah I I think it's good to speculate
about to question Joe Biden who who gets
caught in all kinds of Lies the time but
to your point video of him exists where
he is sort of speaking forcefully he was
influential he did have a career in
politics for some time and I think that
underscores sort of how serious his
decline is I mean he's the oldest
president in the country's history he
wants to be the second he wants to
defeat himself for that title uh but
Trump isn't young Trump is Trump is in
his like what late mid
mid yeah so he's late 70s he's way more
cognitively together than Biden is there
are T I mean even like Chuck Grassley in
Iowa he is in his 80s and he is more
together than than Biden is right now
the fact that Biden is actively slurring
and it's not even a question of just
like we don't like this guy he is
declining so rapidly it's undeniable I
think that's one of the reasons why the
uh Democrats have turned against him we
have all kinds of Democrats who say he's
too old to be there and at least on
paper he has access to the nuclear codes
which really should terrify people I
know he he obviously has handlers behind
the scenes that do most of the stuff for
him like a lot of the decisions that
makes aren't yeah exactly I mean which
one is worse the person in charge of the
nuclear Arsenal and everything else that
goes on at the executive capacity is
completely out to lunch or a bunch of
other people that aren't out to lunch
and clearly are malevolent they're the
ones in charge and he's just a
figurehead I don't know which one is
scarier I think it's actually a little
bit of both right I agree and here's how
I see it Joe Biden's in charge but
incoherent yeah and so people are just
like imag you know we're all sitting at
this big table it's funny because people
can't see it whenever they come here
they're like this room is so big it's
like yeah it's like 15 by 35 or whatever
but the table's massive so you got all
these people sitting around the
situation room and you know a missile
just struck a US military base in Iraq
and then the president do briefed and
he's sitting there and he's got this
look on his face or he's wearing
aviators and eating ice cream because
you know it helps people with
Alzheimer's and then uh they're like Mr
President what do we doing he was like
come on man you know got a got B get go
and they're like oh and they look at
each other like uh yeah whatever you say
Mr President then he leaves and they're
like what what do we do I don't know
what he said like what do we supposed to
do don't worry he'll forget by tomorrow
whatever he was trying to say so just
just do something and I I really do
think this because when you look at
Afghanistan it doesn't even look like a
coherent plan to fail on purpose like
abandoning bam Air Force Base in the
middle of the night and and letting
random people rans sack it I'm like
there are better ways to pull out of
Afghanistan in a way that props up your
enemies and there are better ways to
pull out Afghanistan correctly and
nothing was executed properly and the
stories we learned about the the uh uh
the withdrawal from Afghanistan was that
all of these different military leaders
were just like frantically confused and
didn't know what was going on and this
is how you end up with like you had um
Afghan Security Forces flying
helicopters just land them and get out
and run run run in a random Direction
because there was no Logistics once the
Air Force Base shut down and the us just
stopped these guys are like hello hello
like what's happening like we're cut off
and they're like I'm out of here dude
cuz you're you're no longer working for
cohesive unit seems to me more like Joe
Biden says true and not a shop of
pressure and then everyone's just like I
have no idea what to do and so they just
do whatever it's totally just without
coordination yeah I I think it is a mix
of the two it was funny because uh Biden
did have the coherence to call the then
president of Afghanistan before
everything happened and say oh just lie
to people and tell them that it's okay
because we need time to coordinate the
withdrawal that he pushed back
unilaterally but then they didn't
actually withdraw any of the materials
right the the man is clearly sick uh
anyone even the Liberals I think know it
it's just that they don't want to admit
to the fact that Joe Biden quite clearly
has difficulty so they cope with it by
pointing out some verbal flaw that
Donald Trump had you know a week ago
yeah exactly they point out some flaw in
his wording so he us the wrong word he
referred to Nikki Haley as Nancy Pelosi
which I think was kind of on the nose
basic purose exactly yeah basically are
the same ideologically uh in order to
cope with it yeah and it's just it's
just a mess you know I think leftists
want Biden
because they actually agree with me and
what I said was in 2019 2020 if you
think Donald Trump really is going to
destroy this country and destroy our
democracy and you're a leftist he's your
guy yeah because you vote for Joe Biden
and you are empowering the banksters the
corporations and you are giving them
their strangle hold on this but if you
vote for Donald Trump he'll give you
everything you think is coming
destruction here's the truth they do
agree with me in essence but not on
who's going to cause the destruction
they actually agree with me
wholeheartedly Joe Biden and US Joe
Biden will destroy the country Donald
Trump will fix the country they do want
Joe Biden to destroy the country so they
vote for Joe Biden if they if they if
they actually Trump was that bad they'd
vote for him yeah but the truth is they
know Donald Trump will make America
great again secure the borders bring
back jobs they don't want that they want
Biden's Alzheimer's
ises catastrophe War conflict crisis
they want to be a they want to see the
United States fall apart and and it
makes a lot of sense from the
perspective of the left Empower uh why
you know you wonder why it is the
leftists are supporting the FBI the FBI
is going after Trump supporters that's
perfect one I I've been saying this
consistently uh uh the wi condition for
the left is the start of a civil war not
winning a civil war they they want the
system to shatter in half and that gives
them basically it throws the whole
machine into disarray and then they can
start doing whatever they want imagine
Chaz chop but with no federal Authority
at all nothing to do and it's already
bad enough there's barely any Chaz like
uh the Chaz Garden that's right well
then everyone will definitely starve to
death yeah but I but it's it's we can
make fun of these people for their
inability to actually farm at any
capacity but think about what that means
it means roving bands of communist
barbarians raiding pantries and Farms
because they don't want to starve to
death and they're dangerous violent
extremists so if the country actually
you know if Texas kicks off into some
kind of you know fed versus State
dispute and then you know Trump is
already called on states to deploy their
National Guard several already have I
think 10 different states have sent law
enforcement on National Guard let's say
the conflict actually breaks off we
don't call it a Civil War for the time
being but then Joe Biden makes a move to
try and suspend like oh you know Florida
has been supplying Aid to Texas in this
conflict so they send feds down to
Florida to try and then then state
troopers in Florida are fighting with
FEDS and now we're like holy crap this
has begun these Chaz chop people are
going to be like now's our chance and
they're going to immediately be like the
feds can't stop us local government
can't stop us and the reality is I think
if you look at who's more organized I
would argue that
that in the event something like that
happens the far-left will be more
organized than law enforcement the
reason
is the the the anti faels are in loose
communication with each other but they
have no external threat Factor if the
federal government gets into it with
Texas and it's like it's very light I
don't know if this this will actually
escalate the border patrol is already
sided with Texas National Guard we'll
see where that goes but let's say the
conflict between the feds and this and
and Texas escalates into several other
states it's like a Mexican standoff the
feds are way too preoccupied are not
going to be able to muster up any kind
of forces to stop farle farle extremists
from seizing territory in major cities
and local police cut off from the feds
are going to just ditch they're going to
be like I'm out we remember what
happened when the far leftists went to
the police station in Minnesota in
Minneapolis what happened all the cops
ran full speed out of the building they
were not organized in the way people
think they are the far left is or at
least willing to do crazy things so
that's what I kind of see happening I
don't know
well at least in the case with Texas I
think it's more likely to be protracted
litigation than any uh than anything
else and for political reasons alone I
personally think this is just my opinion
we'll see if you agree with this I think
the Biden Administration is going to
Blink I think that when they see half
the states in the United States are on
paper against them when they see that
the vast majority of the population
including most independent voters are
completely against them with regards to
the Border crisis eventually it'll
become politically too tenuous for Joe
Biden to maintain his position he's
either going to do a 180 or he's going
to get crushed politically and then and
then the most likely outcome is that the
left tries to take a shot at Trump or
something like that unfortunately unless
they false flag something possible so it
depends on what you think how desperate
you think the feds are and how depraved
they are right now the challenge is if
Joe Biden like the border patrol saying
no we agree with Texas on this one we're
not going to we're not going to be
arrested them or stopping them from
securing the Border I mean that's that's
showing the emperor has no clothes Joe
Biden has no command over his law
enforcement agents they win the Supreme
Court ruling on the ability to tear down
these barricades and border patrol just
out the union outright said nah how
desperate will the federal government be
to assert their Authority Federal
Supremacy they may not care that much
Biden may just be feckless and go you
know and just disappear but that creates
another big risk or maybe not maybe it's
their win condition uh showing that
states now have Supremacy in the law
over the federal government because of
what Texas did other states are going to
follow suit it's uh it's blood in the
water the Sharks will come but they've
already been doing so I mean a handful
of states and and cities as well have
been openly ignoring the immigration law
anyway y the sanctuary I mean they
completely ignored Trump they wouldn't
work with him they won't work with ice
or anything like that so there's already
a precedent of so basically it's nothing
new Under the Sun kind of but but it's
an escalation yeah and a serious one at
that it's one thing when you know what
happening with Sanctuary states and
cities federal government will say hey
we want you to you know arrest these
illegal immigrants they say we will not
cooperate with the federal authorities
but when Ice shows up they don't stop
them ice walks in makes the arrests and
they just say we won't assist you in any
of this so it's passive resistance
they've not actually confronted imagine
if in California when Ice shows up to
deport some illegal immigrant California
National Guard blocks them from from
doing so that's where we're at with
Texas so what we've seen with Sanctuary
states and cities so far has just been
passive the Texas move is active
resistance they deployed armed soldiers
if that is the next step and the B
administration's response is well gosh
darn it whatever other states are going
to be like we our laws matter more and
think about what this means for Texas
Texas allows you to have a suppressor
for your gun so long as it's bought in
Texas and they don't require you to get
the Federal registration that you need
to get uh anywhere else which is in
defiance of Federal Regulation based the
NFA yeah so uh the National Firearms Act
and its modifications mean that if you
want to get a suppressor for your gun
you got to fill out this these crazy
Federal forms takes a long time uh you
got to pay $200 I think it takes up to a
year for some people eight months to a
year in Texas they're like no you can
buy one we won't arrest you for it the
feds might get mad about it screw them
already you see the passive rejection of
federal law in Texas and and other
states are following suit with gun
sanctuaries I wonder if if the federal
government really does fear that this is
one grain of sand too many actively
resisting with armed soldiers and they
decide they do want to play hard ball
it's not going to be border patrol
agents walking up and being like well
you know we got to do what we got to do
it's going to be a false flag it's going
to be a scop it's going to be it's going
to be real war and I love this when the
media says conspiracies aren't real and
they say oh conspiracy theory it's like
if you think governments are are
declaring it's it's like the colonial
era Warfare of people marching down the
fields pointing guns at each other
you're you're a and of course the
media wants people to believe that but
real war is going to be the bid
Administration saying I don't care how
suppress Texas let's figure that out and
that would be false flag we got you got
a convoy heading down to the border
right now you got a bunch of private
militia people saying they're going down
to the border and all it takes is one
fed to show up wearing a magad I think I
tend to agree with you that I think the
Biden Administration will blink and I
think what's interesting is that they
are already trying to spin the narrative
as fast as they can so when mayor
released this letter today saying you
know I'm not going to appear in front of
the house um Homeland Security you guys
made it difficult I mean it's a long
letter where he's saying you guys made
it difficult to schedule and then you
asked for written testimony and actually
I'm really good at my job and actually
we've deported tons of people more
people than Trump has ever deported and
you know he is desperately trying to
make the case that he is both good at
his job and also there's a whole section
where he talks about how he's received
accolades from the Biden Administration
he's gotten he's been uh rewarded for
his service and so in some ways it has
made me wonder if mayorcas knows on some
level that Biden could potentially ask
for his resignation as a way to say like
look I'm compromising you with you
Republicans I'll get rid of the DHS
secretary and then you guys have to come
to the table when it comes to
Congressional nominations because that's
what they're saying right now they're
saying actually the only way to change
the Border situation they being you know
Democrats sort of left leaning
politicians the only way to change the
situation at the border is in Congress
and actually the Biden Administration
can't do anything and this is where I
start to think that the Biden
Administration knows they're on the
losing end of this and they are likely
to try and spin or back out of the
position they put themselves in the
funny part is that the thing that might
stop a potential false flag in a greater
border crisis would be Biden's ego
because again he does the strongman
thing he in his mind because he's a
little bit scrambled he's still 30 40
years old he's still beating up corn
popop and stuff like that and so to save
his lagging presidency and really
genuinely try to get another term he
might slip his handlers he might fire
mayorcas uh he may not he may reprimand
him or something like that he could do a
total 180 we've seen this on energy uh
one day he's approving new drilling
leases the next day he's canceling a
pipeline the next day he's okaying more
exports and the next day he's blocking
exports it doesn't even make any sense
completely incoherent that that's why I
was saying I think it's a little bit of
both that there are some people making
independent decisions I I bet a lot of
his staff are going this guy's out of
his mind I'm I'm I'm just going to go do
it I'm going to do whatever I want the
other half are like I have no idea what
he said I'm just going to do something
random and so it's a mix of incoherence
and just people running running you know
their own show it's a bad sign for a
real election there's no clear
leadership in this white house and if
you look at his record it's inconsistent
across the board and a lot of things I
mean again of course you know it's easy
to make fun of her but krent John Pierre
is Con L saying things that then get
immediately disproven or challenged in
the White House Press press by the White
House Press Corps and so the
administration to me reads as weak I
obviously have some of my own bias
because they do a lot of stuff I
wouldn't agree with anyways but their
messaging is constantly trying to spin
and redirect and look the other way and
that to me says that they have no plan
it's very different from the things you
hear coming out of you know not even
just Trump but any you know conservative
leaning politician right now well Karine
Jean Pierre's got her own problems she
rarely knows knows what she's talking
about no she never knows you think she
must be angry at a certain point being
like you guys send me out there and I
look stupid every day but she she makes
it clear that she's angry every single
day that's the that's the thing it's
wild uh it doesn't make you miss jum
pasak at all yeah at least that was
funny because you had the circle back
around memes yeah and dressing like what
was that character from peanuts and she
always wore like the the green shirt and
stuff was it was it Peppermint Patty
maybe tomboy chick with the green shirt
and stuff and and Jen saki yeah and Jen
saki always looked like her and acted
like her too I don't know Peppermint
Patty I feel like Jen made a good
exit of the Biden Administration when
she did they were like two years in she
was like I'm going to pass the torch to
this you know young lady of color and
I'm going to go get my own show and I'm
GNA leave this shipwreck behind she was
good at her job she she made a great
decision she did best decision of her
life as much as people were like I can't
stand her she's lying I'm like yeah yeah
but she she was that's also her job oh
of course to spin but she was good at it
we we just know she's lying and the
Press they're morons and they they they
buy into it Kar Johan Pierre is just
like one of the stupidest people just in
general and it's just it's it's amazing
how every day there's some kind of
Scandal where she says something
moronic and just the whole the white
house looks
ridiculous there I don't blame her for
all of it Biden is ridiculous you know
but she makes Biden look coherent
sometimes that's the whole problem I
mean look at Camala Harris too it's like
uh it's a barrel of monkeys could you
imagine like what if what if Cala Harris
is this super intelligent articulate
witty fast talker and and what happens
is her handlers come to her and say you
will not upstage the president is that
clear and she's like what does that
supposed to mean I mean how am I
supposed to articulate my thoughts in
public and explain this to the people in
a way that's that's manageable if I have
to talk like I'm stupider than Joe Biden
figure it out out she's like oh my God
she goes home to her husband and she's
like they're threatening me that if I
don't that if I make Joe Biden look
stupid I'm in trouble and the next day
she walks out in stage to give her
speech she goes Community is our
community and that's the story of how I
imagine herself practicing in the mirror
every morning and the second gentleman
is like you're doing great just let us
keep the cool house demeaning title
second gentleman I don't really like
that so funny dude she could also be a
method actor like George dubia playing
dum
too i' I've always thought that George W
was actually very cunning and he
realized that he could get away with a
lot more if he played the befuddled like
slightly hazy slightly older
dude and then Dick Cheney takes the rra
because Dick Cheney's there behind the
curtain rubbing his hands together BBS
yeah we're going to kill the children
and then her daughter was going like I I
look up to you Daddy and he's like
that's right I mean granted she was an
old woman when he was president but
still
uh I I think Kam is much you know what I
really can't stand is the people who
assume all these people are stupid MH
when they're like the leftist was say
Donald Trump's a he's so stupid I
watched some ad some guy made against
Donald Trump and they're like his
bankruptcies should have ended his
business but his bank buddies bailed him
out I'm like Donald Trump had 500
businesses and five of them had
bankruptcies and they weren't even his
Core Business that Trump uh the Trump
organization was doing fine and
generating a ton of money if you think
Joe Biden is stupid you are incorrect he
may be incoherent old with a broken
brain by today by today that's fair
that's fair I don't think KL Harris is
stupid I think she's probably doing what
you're describing making herself look as
dumb as possible for some reason that
benefits are you don't get to her
position by being stupid there there
there are people who who want to believe
and it's I think it's more of a leftist
idea that people in positions of power
and wealth are undeserving of their
power and wealth and it may be
undeserving is an opinion depends on
what you mean by undeserving but they
typically are saying like this guy did
nothing to to get where he is Donald
Trump's so stupid his dad gave him the
money no Trump did get money from his
dad but he still had to build all of
this there are a lot of people who
inherited money who went nowhere and
fizzled out people uh who work hard are
smart enough and and have the Merit or
are evil enough are going to get ahead K
Harris sounds really dumb when she gives
speeches but I don't believe for a
second that she's that stupid exactly
yeah I don't think she is necessarily
stupid I think she is somewhat
self-absorbed right like I don't think
she genely entered politics you know to
serve the people not that very many do
although I think there are some who
think maybe in the beginning they can
help uh I think ultimately she saw being
Biden's VP as the chance to springboard
her potential Run for the presidency and
she was never able to pull favorably
enough I mean her likability was always
low even lower than b I know Biden got
to hang out with Obama for a couple
years people had a somewhat friendly uh
view of him but she just became worse
and worse and worse she was almost a
surprising VP pick to me because you
know other than maybe the democra
demographic position she holds her
personality just never resonated with
anyone at all and and you know that Jill
actively hates her I I think literally
they chose her for Biden because here's
this old white dude he's not really woke
to the demographics of the modern
democratic party certainly not to the
left so they decided to get a younger
individual who's female who's of color
or whatever they're people of color or
colored people whatever term they're
using these days on the left it's a it's
a different one every day uh just to
counterbalance and apparently there were
uh stories this was last year even the
year before that that like Jill Biden's
people actively hate Cala Harris's
people like they literally viscerally
hate one another I think they hate each
other yeah just all of them well I mean
Joe Joe would refer to her as the help
in his normal company you know let's
let's talk about the ramifications of
failing Joe Biden Administration that
and that is CNN reports Biden says he
has decided how to respond to attack in
Jordan he didn't say exactly how but the
previous reporting was that Biden was
considering striking Iran directly and I
mean the Iranian government their Naval
vessels in the Persian Gulf in response
to the Drone attack that killed three
and injured 3 4 this many speculate
would be uh could ignite World War II
I'm I'm I got to be honest guys I don't
care for the is it World War III because
it's been said 50 million times over the
past two years by a ton of different
politicians across Europe it may be
already happening but I will say this is
this has
been I think it's very clear the
administration's intention was to Target
Iran directly Lindsey Graham called for
it many other politicians called for it
and this would be a unilateral
declaration of war against a major
Nation people in the United States don't
understand they hear Iran and they think
Iraq you look at the map Iraq is not the
same as Iran Iran is a massive
mountainous developed Nation with
resources the reason why it was easy for
the United States to go into Iraq and
Afghanistan less are developed Nations
the reason why the US has struggled to
go after Iran surface to air missiles
and the US relies on air superiority
plus the mountainous mountainous country
going to war with Iran would be massive
I mean the biggest war since I mean I
don't even know I I I imagine you know
it's it's hard to say because during the
the Cold War period all these are
basically proxy wars Vietnam Korea uh
Etc but a war with Iran would be would
be massive Joe Biden may be on the brink
of of of making that move and we can
only hope that if he does Iran decides
not to make a formal
declaration I'm hoping that too uh one
thing I would say is that it's it
wouldn't just be a war with Iran though
it would also be a war with Syria
it would presumptively potentially at
least be a war with Iraq their
government could end up getting
overthrown by the Shia majority and then
they install someone that will side with
the Iranians and the syrians too it
would be the most major conflict at the
very least since that we've been in
since Vietnam technically since World
War II I I don't know enough about the
differing uh views between Iran and
Afghanistan or the Taliban but I'm
wondering well they're Sunni I think
mainly right so I'm wondering what the
possibility that Iran goes to a the
Taliban and says we can maintain those
weapons and that equipment for you have
fun right weaponize the Taliban against
the United States and and and the US's
allies in the region with all the
weapons left by the United States in
Afghanistan I I swear it's like they did
it on purpose it's absolutely insane
that we are facing war with Iran and
literally next door is billions of
dollars in war machines left by Joe
Biden's failed Administration well Iran
has its own weapon systems too they they
they're no slouches when it comes to
missile systems they've done pretty well
for themselves right they wouldn't be
able to achieve air superiority but
definitely trying to occupy an area of
that size is a little bit different from
going into Gaza or something like that I
think the people yeah I think the people
are underestimating the risk actually
and my hope is that Biden doesn't get
his false flag event or whatever else he
needs to start a war there he gets
shuffled out of office Trump is back he
knows how to negotiate with these
countries and then hopefully we can put
the genie back in the bottle that's the
biggest hope do you think it could hold
on for that long though I really hope so
yeah because I mean the alternative is
millions of dead people probably so I
know it's not good that's that's the
hardest thing about the Biden
Administration which is that it is
volatile and also seems to benefit from
uh the anxiety it creates in voters so
in some ways I could see a scenario
where you know Joe Biden I I don't know
how consciously but wants the American
voters to think we're on the brink of
War for as long as possible POS which
ultimately a much more unstable position
with any other foreign government that
we're negotiating with the real danger
though is that you know that America's
enemies would like Biden to be reelected
and being a wartime president tends to
lead to higher reelect ability now I
don't know that that's the case because
Trump is also he's he's a former
president so the the the metric is
different than we've seen in a long time
but the real risk is that Iran will
deliberately antagonize or one of these
other countries specifically to get Joe
Biden
reelected wild it's crazy how obvious it
is that the International Community
regards Trump as the stronger of the two
candidates well I was just thinking like
what if Trump starts negotiating with
people like with the assumption that
he'll be in charge because it's kind of
like we saw a little bit of that with
the whole Texas thing when he said
saying send right I was like huh and and
when that happened when Trump said you
know other states who support Texas you
should send your National Guards there
was a moment where I thought Democrats
are going to
again go after him for saying I was
afraid to even say that but it's like I
mean Donald Trump is effectively
attempting to act as though he is the
president like like the acting president
or or pseudo president in Exile or
something it's basically an election
strategy it seems to be working he's
four points ahead in the RCP aggregate
almost yeah I mean he's he's running six
and a half points ahead of where he was
at any time in 2016 almost uh 15 points
ahead of where he was in 201 20 it's
actually massive and he's about to win
the Nobel Peace Prize I mean this man
can do it all peace key word that is
true key word it is interesting that
Trump has uh clearly cemented himself in
my opinion as the Republican uh nominee
going forward and we're still sort of
dancing around the primaries like this
is this is going to be a thing that
happens do you have uh do you have
thoughts on Nikki Haley's statement that
she's going to stay until uh super
Tuesday she she's going to get
humiliated in her home state and she
either drops out then or she stubbornly
stays in through the very end hoping
that Donald Trump croaks or is
disqualified in a brokered convention
one of those two things will happen she
either drops right after or she stays in
through the whole thing and never drops
and just is a thorn in the side we're
doing a live event uh on March 5th that
I was like we'll do a live super Tuesday
event which makes no sense to be
completely honest because it's not
really super Tuesday it's this weird
pseudo primary where every Trump Tuesday
yeah what are you talking about but
because Nikki keeps screeching like a
banshee from the background people are
like I guess there's some kind of race
going on yeah so I I feel kind honestly
I feel bad calling it a super Tuesday
event maybe we should just call it like
Trump wins again Tuesday just an average
Tuesday in
November average exactly you should do
Taco Tuesday in here and everyone eats
tacos and just like sits there Nicki
Haley was getting votes for some reason
anyway she's 80 points
behind the the I was watching um MSNBC
The Night of the Iowa caucus and they're
all sort of anxious and upset about
what's going on they're like well I mean
what Trump's team is really trying to
figure out if is is if he can get more
than 50% because you know that's the
victory they actually want we don't
think he's going to get it and then he
pulled it like 51 and then New Hampshire
was even higher and I loved it how D
santis edged her out I was so so
grateful about that like I was never
Team D santis but I swore up and down I
would never insult Dan santis or any of
his influencers again and I hold by that
if he managed to Edge her out in Iowa
despite being behind in the polls just
by two points but it was just enough so
that Nikki Haley she couldn't even she
didn't even have time to change her
speech you remember that like clearly
she expected it's a two person race well
who are these two people I am not yeah
but then Ron dropped out yeah yeah so he
maybe she's just psychic maybe she knew
she was pressing Ron to get out uh she's
such a strange candidate to me because
she seems so unlikable and I think South
Carolina is going to be so rough I mean
every there are there any other South
Carolina leading uh elected officials
that can endorse her I mean Henry
McMasters has always been behind Trump
they've all endorsed Trump they've all
endorsed Trump it's just here here's a
question though uh you can answer who's
more dislikable Camala Harris or Nikki
Haley because for me it's difficult to
actually determine because I mean
they're similar in many ways so I guess
I wonder what like the only way I can
rephrase it is if someone called you of
the two which would be more insulting
and I don't know that either uh do you
have a guess on who wait you're saying
Nikki Haley versus Kamala Harris which
one is more unlikable Kamala Harris and
and if someone called me Nikki Haley I'd
be like hey if someone called me Kamala
Harris I'm like hey that's true like
kamla Harris is accused of many things
in order to build up her career with
Will Brown no no no Nikki Haley is too
is she really what yeah no she had
several allegations that she had affairs
did and at the very least she made her
husband change his name which isual but
like the thing about Nikki Haley is I'll
put it this way would you rather be
called a or a
warmonger it's like I know it's it's a
good question's both
apparently well I say this is the
problem equivalent oh all right well
that's what I was saying it's like
they're not necessarily one's not
necessar better than other than the
other like some people would rather be a
harlot than someone who goes and bombs
kids you know what I mean I'd rather be
a mom see that's that's that's the
difficult thing I think both of them
want to be both though that's the
problem which is also upsetting that's
really that's that's like a funny bit
kamla Harris and Nikki Haley arguing
with each other in a VP debate over who
was going to kill more
kids become one to get the other one
Nikki Haley isn't going to be Trump's VP
nope no who do you think Trump would
pick as a VP uh I I don't know exactly
who but here's here's my general
thoughts it'll either be a charismatic
female so somebody like a Cary lake or
Tulsi Gabbert or a nonar
trage withis who will of the spotlight
that's why he Pence to that's why I
don't think it'll be ramas Swami or
Tucker Carlson they' both be fine
choices but I think they're off the
table non-charismatic unassuming like
like a Tim Scott male Doug B if it's
female Trump trump has no problem with a
with a fiery female being got be I think
chrisy Nome is a good choice for him VP
is not about the second best it's about
who gets Trump demographic he doesn't
get Chris Christy gnome can help him get
Suburban women absolutely especially
considering what's going on with Joe
Biden economics in schools you get a
middle-aged woman with Charisma and
Trump is it's it's it's great he needs
that yeah I I think Christin Nome is
definitely in the top three or four I
think tulsey gabbard's probably up there
too you could definitely you could
definitely do worse she has really had a
Redemption Arc number one and number two
she is very well spoken yeah she she's
got a lot of Charisma and she's a former
Dem so she brings potentially some left
leing Independence to say well you know
Donald Cho she used to be the Democrat
I'm kind of a soft
Democrat could work anti-war leftists
would be like I don't like Trump but I
think Tulsi in there is good absolutely
this what I was saying uh in 20 like
2020 that if Trump chose Andrew Yang as
an economic adviser and announced that
he'd be cabinent position and tul see
gabard as National Security adviser he'd
win in a landslide of course the left
took that statement and clipped out part
where I said he's going to win in a
landslide and cut out the context of if
he legalized marijuana pardoned all the
people in federal prison over marijuana
dealing and then made Tulsi gabard but
uh I digress Tulsi gabard uh as someone
advising him on National Security is
exactly what most populists want to hear
no Wars there was an amazing article uh
I think it was what was it Pat Buchanan
the American conservative whatever said
it said fire Bolton hire Tulsi gabard
this is a a a conservative fire brand
saying Tulsi gabard should be in that
position position CU she won't get us
involved in these Garbage Wars we can
all agree hey we don't like her policy
on guns or whatever she's she's evolved
on these issues but she was against
nuclear energy and she was for gun
control these are bad things but she has
military service she opposes foreign
intervention and put her in that
position and Trump jump several Trump's
jumping several points the the military
service part would be a big thing as
well especially since one of the things
Trump is going to have to do if he's
reelected is reform the military oh yeah
he he's I mean he got to deify it you've
got to get the recruitment levels up
preferably keep it State side or in
Allied countries and not send it over
into Iran like Biden apparently plans
possibly to do uh if he's going to do
that having a VP who could go directly
to the Troops who could go to like the
recruitment center and stuff and
actually like level with people I think
would be very very important let's uh
let's talk about the story from the
Daily Mail Ronda santis demands ilen
Omar is thrown out of Congress and
deported following speech declaring she
is Somalia first as she faces calls to
resign yo this was wild did you guys see
the speech from Elan Omar she's not
she's Bas literally insane she's talking
to a bunch of somalis saying our
president my president my country things
like this saying that we're going to
fight for our country and people are
like whoa whoa whoa like she is she is
speaking like she is not an American
citizen we are going to invade Kenya
yeah people were talking about how in
the past she's been bullhorn saying
Somalia my country and then cors herself
so Ronda santis he's got a tweet he said
expel from Congress denaturalize and
Deport uh I just I just got to say this
is like I don't know how you describe it
what Ronda Santa said is more
politically what's the right word for
this fiery spicy politically chared
spicy than what maybe anyone has said in
politics the sitting governor of Florida
called for stripping a US citizen of her
citizenship and sending her back to the
country she claims to have allegiance to
look dropping out of the race was a
great thing for him he's feeling more
confident he's feel yeah he's like my
political career is over
theal the expulsion definitely needs to
happen though El Omar has done this over
and over she's constantly embarrassing
the United States ironically enough the
Democratic party they're crazy to even
have her aboard at this point and you
know that some of the neoliberals would
like to see her gone but she's a an
ethnic female she practices Islam they
don't want to touch that with a 50 foot
pole they don't want they don't want to
lose their clout their it's not just
that it's that ill Omar represents a
very Somali District so she has local is
Untouchable exactly yeah they're they're
going to keep voting her in there is
potential competition for her from a
more conservative perspective you if you
got someone who is like Muslim uh Somali
but they were conservative not
Progressive I think they would win but
you'd still have to have someone
basically preaching to the group of
people that they represent Somalia and
not Minnesota but that's where we're at
so anyway Ron has uh uh as you said it
was very good for him to drum out of the
race I wonder what would have happened
if he said things like this while he was
running perhaps he should
have his support probably would have
risen if he had said something like that
about El Omar yeah I think so I think
that this is sort of more fiery than he
was because the big accusation was that
he didn't have a
yeah he was sort of he was sort of a
limp noodle at times when he was running
I I think he was trying to like
counterbalance himself against like
Trump's mean tweets or something like
that it just didn't work what could you
imagine what Trump supporters would be
saying if Ronda STIs tweeted this would
they be forced to defend ilhan Omar just
to be an OB santis some uh uh some of
the real hardcore influencers would have
you believe that I would have laughed my
ass off oh yeah no for sure I feel like
if he had tweeted stuff like this it
would have left the door open to him
having a position in in the Trump
Administration whereas then things got
too tense there's too much there's
there's too much that's happened now
whereas if he had said stuff like this
they would have felt more aligned I I
think I think there's still a
possibility to santis ends up in the
Trump adist I I I could see him as being
uh in the cabinet maybe not as running
mate cuz again well they can't both be
Florida right he's a little bit I mean
if he's making tweets and and like
this then he's too charismatic for Trump
to have his a running man right I I got
to be honest I do believe that there's a
handful of trump personalities Trump
supporters where if Ron tweeted that
while running they would say oh come on
I mean like we're all critical of illan
but the idea of stripping someone from
their CI citizenship is fascist Ron is a
fascist now they're going to be like
based there would be some Trump support
there there are always going to be a few
hardcore fans who get cognitive
dissonance of course absolutely no yeah
yeah of course I I would have should
have said this I'd have been like yes
Ron break from your cocoon become who
you were meant to be Trump you have
found your running mate cuz where does
he go from here I I feel like I asked
this every other day but you know I feel
like he's going to start a podcast on
Rubble he'd make more money he's gonna
join us here on alternative media he
really you should try to get Ronda Santa
aboard well he his campaign banned
banned their staff from appearing on
show what if he comes to our regular
Tuesday event you know be funny like
could you imagine why would they have
bad blood with your show this like the
natural place IR would fit right trumpy
and we are friends with some of like uh
like Will Chamberlain worked for him and
and Will's a friend a good friend and
he's been on the show several times uh
but there were uh attempts had been made
we can't reach out to their people and
they were just like they kept saying no
and then we got word that basically
theis campaign said do not go on Tim
cast IRL which is the weirdest thing I
think they would have gotten more votes
if they had they would have and I think
what happens is they were getting advice
from you know like the Ken Griffin types
these establishment rhino know you know
stagi unaa Party Guys lindsy Graham gave
him a call yeah and they're like go on
CNN go on cable TV the podcasts aren't
real and then look at v ramaswami v saw
what what V was probably sitting there
and he was like Ron's doing everything
wrong I'm going to do what he should do
it's going to work and it did he was
never going to be president I told the
this and you know we had him on the
culture War show earlier uh last year
and I said to him I'm a fan of a he's a
great guy I said I don't think you're
going to win I would like to vote for
you in the primary but I think Trump's
going to win anyway and he's like well
you know look I'm running we'll see blah
blah blah but I'm like come on a a
firsttimer young guy with no political
background at 0% is is is very very very
very unlikely to win a GOP nomination
especially with Trump running as an
effective incumbent I think anybody who
thought they were anyone else was going
to beat Trump in this is is delusional
except when V said they going to stop at
nothing to remove Trump in which case I
should stay in this as long as I can the
crazy thing is dude spent like $30
million of his own money what was the
number was it 30 million I know he sold
I think it was more than that actually
yep of his own money trying to maintain
this I respect it and then what did he
do once Iowa came up bad he he bowed out
and endorsed Trump right away
masterfully played Ron could have done
all that and Ron didn't but I just I
just want to say this how hilarious
would it be if after the election Ronda
santis is termed out he's he's done he
doesn't run he just comes out and he's
like I'd like to thank the people of
Florida the good people who supported me
as I was your Governor uh I now want to
say go to rumble.com Rond DeSantis to
watch my new show where I talk about
stripping immigrants of their
citizenship and deporting them back to
their home countries we're going to
build the wall and then he just goes
totally off and he makes this like you
know graper Rumble Channel and he's just
like super you know we're going to build
the borders for funding gone I've always
wondered why people when when they they
get like so much money and and so much
clout that clearly you know they've got
a continuing career they'll always be
able to pay their bills but none of them
ever like go crazy and start doing like
crazy stuff and saying crazy things or
only very rarely and it's actually a
mystery because you could get even more
attention doing that and it's like you
could Corner the market this is this is
listen listen this is why I want
everyone to go to facts.com fcts rap.com
and buy Tom McDonald and Beno song I
really do mean it
um like you know talking to these guys
seeing where they're at it's looking
where they're at it's looking really
really good but there's a reason why I
want Beno to hit the Billboard Hot 100
it's like you're
saying people don't do crazy things it's
all stodgy routine and boring nothing is
shocking the system nothing is waking
people up we got to get a little weird
with it like Frank Reynolds in It's
Always Sunny he's old I mean for those
of you that have seen the show he's an
old guy he's super rich and he decides
to live in squalor with these like
degenerate bar owners CU he's like I
want to get I only got a few years left
of my life I want to get freaky with it
just do weird stuff I'm not saying to
literally you know have everyone be
degenerates but one thing I've often
said is you got a lot of powerful
influential people on our side who
believe in Freedom Liberty meritocracy
responsibility they're not spending
their money doing anything they'll go on
their shows and they'll say stuff like
it's so bad that I see Joe Biden doing
this man we got to get out there and
vote good thing I'm glad they're doing
it and then they'll be like so make sure
you go to my website you know corn
starch. comom and buy the cornstarch and
I'm like it's fine sponsorship supports
the show but outside of being a fire
brand and a preacher for good issues
what are people doing to actually invade
to to to like we're not going to win a
culture War by standing on a Hilltop
screaming you have to actually try and
seize territory in culture and and
physical reality
so I'm I I just I get frustrated when I
see prominent individuals who become
extremely successful in news media
podcasting and then they just sit down
in their chair and they do nothing
they're like I'm good I I I've seen
people stable off they're like well I
may I make I'm making good money right
now I'm going to do nothing else and I'm
GNA and I'm going to work a couple hours
a day and then I'm going to go sit on
the beach all day and I'm like man it's
like once they got comfortable and they
got money they said I don't want to move
from this position I I want to see
people with these big shows being like
I'm going to work 20 hour days 16 hour
days and we're going to win this cult
War we need more of that if Ben chapiro
and Tommy tonnel get to the Hot 100 do
you think they'll release a remix
featuring Rona santis no I think that
would be the funniest thing I do want to
say this in in essence we've already won
that cultural battle and it's one that
you know Carter and I have been fighting
for for for over a year now because it's
not just about politics it's about how
the industry keeps out anyone who's not
a part of the club just in general so
they change the metrics they say oh we
don't count this anymore we don't count
that because they don't like the fact
that independent individuals can build
something to challenge The Establishment
the woke establishment and their
narrative control and take
over it's going to be real funny I mean
it already is funny that bench CH is the
number one rapper in the world on iTunes
but it's goingon to be real funny when
hepped he he he doesn't he just talks
fast so he pretty good though it's this
year is already off the hook yeah we're
only in January but but again this is
why you know for one Tom McDonald has
been putting out a bunch of really
amazing stuff for a long time
challenging the culture and it's funny
what they say they're like here's a guy
who looks like a drug dealing gang
banger and he's rapping against this
stuff and I'm like duh that's the point
that you you you you do not have to
combine the style the looks the
aesthetic with being a criminal you can
be a good person and try and look a
certain way and have fashion so every
time he's been getting big he's been
getting big hits forever they block him
out they lie they create reasons as to
why he shouldn't chart why he doesn't
deserve to get written up about and this
guy Tom McDonald's has got numerous
songs just all of them hitting like 10
20 million or not all of them but a lot
of them and you get people in the
industry now acting like they don't know
who he is the reality is they know who
he is they do not want any of us to be
able to supplant their machine but I
want to let everyone know the good
news the digital media industry is in
freef Fall Absolut Tech crunch just laid
a bunch of people off by this time next
year it's going to be nothing left but
us so we are winning and I'm glad to see
it and what I'm hoping for now is with
things like Public Square we're now
seeing the expansion of these uh these
Public Square esque companies companies
that believe in American values
sponsoring more and more people in
various Industries it's about time these
big companies that are on Public Square
find some musicians to sponsor find some
athletes to sponsor find some drivers to
sponsor I saw a pro athlete at uh uh
Nitro Circus wearing a Public Square
shirt Nitro Circus is people on BMXs and
roller blades and skateboards doing back
back flips and scooters that means
you've got little kids hanging out in
the audience and they see they see a big
Public Square Banner Travis Pastrana I
think he might be on Black Rifle that's
us winning and dominating we have to
build things so it's silly I guess to be
like Ben shapir is the number one rapper
we need more than that more than coffee
companies every podcast in the world
selling coffee nowadays but what we're
doing we've got a physical location
being built right now for our coffee
shop the club will probably be probably
be open in a few months so much sooner
than the actual coffee shop we're going
to be doing the live show on March 5th
at the the C brew club in Martinsburg
West Virginia so the goal here is to
build physical locations where people
can meet up and then you don't need me
to sit here in front of a camera and
tell you what to think you guys can go
talk to each other long story short
people who are successful in the space
need to build things and work 10 times
harder than they are yeah there are a
lot of people that sort of sit on their
Laurels I mean look at uh even and this
might not be an example you'd even agree
with look at Howard Stern for example
the man spends the better part of two
decades fighting against censorship I
mean out of self-interest it wasn't out
of any major ideological principles then
once he gets his break he's got the
contract sign he's got all the money in
the world well bye he just uh he just uh
goes off and starts becoming boring
exactly and already gets fired although
he was on heroin so that sort of I mean
look at look at uh uh Jimmy Kimmel The
Man Show having women jump on trampol
there are a million memes about his his
hypocrisy yep too many people are
grifters and the funny thing is the left
likes to call people uh
anti-establishment anti-establishment
people grifters as if it's easier to be
anti-establishment as opposed to being
protected by the censorship machine we
were talking to Steve Baker yesterday
journalist who's being criminally or
they're trying to criminally charge over
January 6 he said there were three
journalists who were together and went
in the capital and film things one of
the guys worked for a local news outlet
with a big local news Outlet camera and
he filmed a bunch of stuff
the other guy filmed on his phone the
guy filmed on his phone released a
report for the New Yorker calling them
insurrectionists M no charges or I think
uh yeah what happened he didn't get
charged at all I or he got very light
sentence if anything I think he got
nothing he said I think he didn't get
charged I think they were just like oh
you're good and then the guy with the
big news camera got what he get eight
months yeah and he he comes home to his
news station saying like I got all this
footage I'm like great then they cut him
off and stopped talking to him and then
they raided his house and arrested him
despite the fact he is a credential
member of the press with press camera
with journalists filming that's that
that's the game so for all these people
like Howard Stern they know Butters
their bread they are weak pathetic
individuals and that's all that's all
they've got is I will do whatever you
say they're they're you know they're
they're Anakin Skywalker getting all
this great power and then dropping to
their knees for the emperor and saying I
will do whatever you say I don't want to
lose what I got cowards I mean I think
that's why you were saying before some
of these people come off campaigns why
don't they do something Bolder and I
always think it's because ultimately
they want back into the machine they
aren't sure if if things are over and
that might shift now I mean you guys
would be better able to gauges than I
would give in both of your careers but
because Alternative forms of content and
media have really become dominant they'
they're they're not just something some
people are doing they are actual viable
careers maybe we'll see a difference now
but I think that risk of not only am I
going to lose potential income sources
but also I'm going to lose my position
where I have influence scares people
from doing anything bold well the other
thing is if you create an infrastructure
in which like non-woke individuals who
don't have a problem with edgy content
or or something dissident something that
goes against the grain if they engage in
business making and so forth and then
reinvest in other people too you can
create sort of axicon of income of
support in which you don't have to have
that sort of self-censorship anymore
because you've got sort of the platforms
Etc uh you've got like new tech you've
got like Rumble bitshoot Etc uh you've
got people who are capable of investing
and they expect a return on investment
and then you have people who give them
that return and it's sort of just a
reciprocal
process Let's uh this is a fun one this
next story from cnr.com there is a
member of Congress who as it turns out
is a 911 truther and he's a Democrat and
he's a Democrat who illegally pulled a
fire alarm it's rep Bowman Bowman
responds to resurfaced 911 truther blog
I regret posting any any anything about
any of these people yo this is for Real
New York rep Jamal Bowman issued a
statement to The Daily Beast after the
outlet reported that Bowman promoted
wild conspiracy theories on his personal
blog in a Monday report according to the
outlet Bowman's blog was operated during
the same time as a middle school
principal at the Cornerstone Academy for
Social Action in the Bronx as far back
as
2014 around February 2016 the blog was
scrubbed of all posts which ranged from
poetry to essays topics ranging from the
Florida account to the Y2K bug that
stoked fear the century blah blah blah
the turn of the century and speculation
the 911 Terror attacks were an inside
job by the US government the notion of
build the notion of building seven
collapse being control demolition which
was a large component of the inside job
theory has been denied by by Nest we
most of us know this quote 2001 planes
used as missiles targets Twin Towers
reads a stanza and an archived poem by
the New York representative per The
Daily Beast later in the day Building 7
also collapsed hm multiple explosions
heard before and during the collapse H
allegedly two other planes the Pentagon
Pennsylvania hijacked by terrorist
minimal damage done minimal debris found
hm the poem
continues we blamed Obama we blamed
Osama sorry went to warn Iraq captured
sdam Hussein killed him Bin Laden in is
AF is Afghan so we went to war there too
in the poem Bowman credits 2005
documentary Loose Change and the 2007
documentary series Zeitgeist which
explore theories behind the terror
attacks that counter official narratives
okay
he says I don't believe anything these
cranks have said and my life's work has
proven that blah blah blah nah I'm sorry
I got to tell you I don't know a single
person who has written about 911 truth
seeing Loose Change 911 and Zeitgeist
and has changed their mind yeah I I
don't know a single person he changed
his mind once he got exposed while being
in Congress that's that's is why we
archive everything because we don't know
who's going to run for office and it's
good to have the receipts but then what
if the conspiracy theory is that
Bowman's actually secretly based and
trying to uncover deep conspiracies
within the government oh God I remember
Ze gist and then they had that section
tacked onto it with like methro and
stuff like that yeah the religion
section and I think uh good documentary
it was fun I I I got to go with aam's
Razer on this one Bowman is a grifter he
was lying then because it earned him
internet points and he thought he would
get recognition he would get traffic or
whatever how old is how old would he
have been when he first wrote would he
he would have been fairly young I think
no this is 2014 it said but he's not so
old now is he this since 2014 he's
posting this stuff yeah but how old was
he then I guess I guess yo it's kind of
wild to think that was 10 years ago so
right now he's 47 yeah so he so he's
reasonably young
37 bad poetry 37 hey I'm 36 don't call
me old Tim no what I'm saying is you're
an adult you have a world view you have
a perspective yeah you don't just change
your mind like what happened in Bowman's
mind where he was like at one point
saying what caused Building 7 a collapse
it was never hit hit by a plane then 10
years later to be like oh he was like
I'm going to have so many Facebook
followers after this we thought about it
enough to write like to make art about
it and the Poetry doesn't even make is
is there anywhere where I can see this
full poem because it does it does not
appear to rhyme no the HS is his best
rhyming word maybe it was like spoken
word maybe he was preparing to perform
it somewhere the real the real story uh
he he invented slam poetry right there's
like an alternative reality where Jamal
Bowman has its own blog and his own
successful like Rumble Channel and he's
talking about 911 truth stuff slam slam
poetry was invented by a dude obsessed
with
Z you heard it here first ladies and
gentlemen he was 35 at the time that's
what daily B says he was 35 the time and
he maintained an online Journal
Relentless dstr strongback
blogspot.com it gets better and better
I'm sorry I did not see this one on my
2024 bingo card that he's a 91 when he
change his mind recently he never did
he's just lying right now yeah he was
lying before or now or possibly both
which means he's a good politician and a
good Democrat yeah there's no way that
he he would like tomorrow a new poem
comes out like I was just
kidding he's not going to get punished
for this by the way we we all know this
he can literally pull a fire alarm to
try to uh prevent a vote from taking
place and nothing happens that's crazy
hey look we got his blog here because we
went to the way back machine and and uh
let's see we got December 18th 2014 poor
Bowman look man I don't care if you
believe in Crazy conspiracies I don't
believe if you I don't care if you
believe in sane conspiracies just give
me your logic I'll argue with you if I
disagree but what I don't respect is
Bowman clearly believing these things
and then acting like he doesn't yeah but
that explains him being a politician I
guess he should become our nation's Poet
Laureate I don't understand what's
happening he should be the next White
House Press Secretary but only speak in
poems that's sort of rhyme but also
maybe not
okay I propose we forgive Bowman for
pulling that fire alarm no jail time
expunged from his record if he comes out
and admits he does believe 911 was an
inside job and he performs his poem on
the floor Congress he performs his poem
here that's true okay I don't think this
is loading I think it's Jamal Bowman's
people are scrubbing it as fast as poss
no this is this is archive.org it might
be on archive. today as well archive.org
is known to scrub things for political
reasons really archive. today archive.
they're not as reliable it's it's not as
reliable it may or may not I I tried
archive today yeah I I use it all the
time although for some reason I can't
get it to load on the laptop I'm using
in the hotel the hotel is like that's a
risky website don't go there yeah no it
just never loads all right we got
something love the
world oh here we go it's loading
Bowman's Mick Loving it no it's going
it's giving us the this this business
business again yeah okay he performs the
poem and then trash house signs him as
an artist and he starts rapping the poem
a May 2011th poem called
recapitulate in which he talks about 911
truism planes use his missiles yeah it's
not just one he was he was thinking
about it he needs to do a rap with Ben
Shapiro dude come on you mean like that
would be the best crossover ever it
would explode the internet and destroy
it forever that'd be great especially if
it was about 91 truth do you know
anybody who watched loose change or
Zeitgeist was a fan of the film in some
capacity and today has been like no I I
think it's all wrong I've never seen
Loose Change although I did watch
Zeitgeist back in the day back you know
when it was first released and I thought
it was fun I thought it was entertaining
and I was like uh you know I'll keep an
open mind or something but I was never
really a truth or dude I wonder I wonder
if this is retaliation for the fire
alarm thing cuz this is this is
character assassination what they're
doing to this guy look what they wrote
both Zeitgeist and change were favorites
of mass shooter Jared Laughner who
killed six people and injured 13 more
including then Gabby gords in a rampage
in tucon Arizona in January 2011 the
only reason you include that which is
like a nonsense statement Zeitgeist and
loose change were seen by millions of
people the only reason you include that
is because you're trying to character
assassinate Bowman they must be like you
are being punished for doing this maybe
he's like Eric Adams getting raided by
the FBI about two fraking weeks after he
criticizes Biden's border policy maybe
it's the same maybe maybe they thought
that he was going to criticize the admin
the regime I don't know I can't see what
website we're on right now but Daily
Beast is the one who broke the article
which I would assume they oh it's like
they would they would be like good job
with that fire alarm that was that was
hilarious maybe but some Bowman did
something because Daily Beast is
basically like deep State media yeah
that's why I I'm surprised that they are
going after him he must there must be a
reason there's got to be obviously is
not the fire I mean the fire alarm they
could care less about they were happy to
come him Bowman went to Pelosi and was
like I don't know if I can do this
anymore man Trump's just not that bad a
guy and they're like he's cracking got
we got to shut him down promise you
promise me you'd tell me the truth about
9/11 if I just
ran no how about he he finally completed
his mission breaking into the archives
and found all the records and the only
reason he ever ran was to try and get
access to previous information and they
found him out there's got there's got to
be something weird going on because The
Daily Beast especially would not
criticize well basically any Democrat
for such a thing they would hide it they
would cover it up look at this justify
it they'd be like oh well it's it's a
youthful indiscretion this is crazy they
said there can be no mistaking that
these are the subjects of Bowman's poem
he refers to Zeitgeist director Peter
Joseph by name shout out to John Perkins
William Cooper Michael Moore Peter
Joseph and Adam Curtis he wrote John
Perkins is the author of the book
secrets of an economic Hitman and
William Cooper was a radio host and hero
of the militia movement and of Oklahoma
City bomber Timothy McVey known for
fevered ramblings about aliens the
Illuminati and the supposed man-made
origin of HIV and AIDS Cooper died in a
Sho with law enforcement in November
2001 Michael Moore and Adam Cur are both
leftwing documentary makers why are why
are they smearing Bowman in this way
bringing up the most extreme individuals
ever it's like it's like saying Bowman
was seen on video drinking water Hitler
also drank water that's what they're
doing maybe maybe after the fire alarm
incident maybe he's political dead
weight and they're worried about that so
they're trying to force him out I was
thinking similar who wants his seat who
do they want to put in his position yes
to coordinate someone else for it they
Prim I think I mean they the election
he's being he's up for re-election uh in
November this is they just dumped asset
on his campaign Daily Beast said you're
out so something must have happened
where they went to him the look
political individuals don't play games
like this unless they have no choice the
first move by any anyone in any kind of
business is going to be
can we convince someone to do what we
want them to do easily you know when you
before going to war you try and get your
your you know the Rival country to do
what you want them to do peacefully
because it saves money time and energy
you don't you know save save money I
have to imagine someone went to Bowman
and said we don't want you to run we
want you to retire and he was like no I
won't do it and they were like do not
run against us and he was like I'm
running and I'm going to win and this is
what happens well it's sort of like what
happened with Carrie Lake there with the
uh the head of the head of the Arizona
GOP openly telling her hey there's a
bunch of people that don't want you to
run for office wouldn't put it past the
Democrats I mean they're just as shady
and there are other Democrats who are
I'm just looking it up right now there
are Democrats who have already announced
to challenge him for the primary so
there he's not so one of one of them is
one of them is uh in on the joke
presumptively one of them was a huge fan
of his poetry back in the day it it
could be simply that opposition and
research found this and then gave it to
the DA beast and said have fun totally
but why would they even run with it
unless they had a problem with Bowman
because he's a Democrat yep that's the
point that's crazy this this story gets
crazy first at first I'm like this is
just a funny story about how Bowman's
911 truth are and now it's just like
there's another conspiracy that we've
uncovered and the media is going to
write crazy right-wing conspiracy theory
that Bowman blah blah blah is being
sidelined or whatever yes dude there's
no reason for anyone to go after him
politically like this if they just said
we found his blog and it's kind of weird
but he said he apologized for it and
moved on I'd be like oh but to lump in
like like Mass Shooters and and
terrorists and name drop them in the
article with him there's crazy claims in
I found his blog and I'm like read the
you find it I'll send you the link but I
there's no guarantee because it gave me
the same gear for it's um there are a
lot of people trying to access it right
now well maybe maybe that's the probably
but yeah the one I can't even say what
he said in the one below recapitulate
but there's a couple what's the subject
can you say what the subject matter is
how he was conceived
this blog is wild we'll save that one
for the members portion of the show I
I'm going to need this link as well
immediately sted oh my God we all must
know I don't know I don't think I want
to
know it gave you the gear symbols for
like a while yeah but now I've got the
whole thing at my disposal oh I have I
have it now too do you you just got a
hang there what year did you pick um I
actually just Googled read like I they
linked the article iness Rel well this
went to an archived one so I don't know
this he did this October 24th
of gee I don't know if I can find the
year but yeah just recapitulate is the
name of it he was he he was committed to
this blog are you seeing it too because
I sent it to Hanah clir and slack just
to see if it would work I can see
recapitulate yeah is the inappropriate
word rhymed with it or is it just
basically poetry what am I reading right
now to give me a hint I I did I did the
control find for the the H to make sure
it was the right poem and you just can
you just post it and like I could try it
yeah just send it to me yeah see if we
can get this thing up take a look at
what this guy was talking about can you
imagine his staff right now his
communication person was like is there
anything else and he's like I can't say
who who is to say or maybe they all know
maybe he's constantly writing poetry in
the office this is how he like delivers
memos to people he's got a pseudonym on
Reddit maybe or cuz that's a good
question though is there another like if
he abandoned this one what what else is
there dude I bet he's got a Reddit he's
got a Reddit account an old one that he
a frequent ship poster on 4chan as well
I would I mean 4chan's harder to track
but you can find his account on Reddit
and figure out what he was posting yeah
I bet he's got wild stuff in there we
should we shouldn't it shouldn't be so
crazy a world that we're actually
sitting here seriously speculating about
that
too what I'm really what I'm really
interested in is is what did he do to
get the machine to come after him like
this probably it's just the fact that he
had the fire alarm incident and stuff
and they thought maybe he'd lose yeah
they probably just said oh well we're
not 100% sure and you know we're going
to be kind of close in the house and the
Senate Anyway come the next election so
you know get lost yeah but he he'd have
to have resisted they go to him and say
you're not going to win re-election
because of what you did and he and he's
saying like no I can do it they're like
you're going to get roasted in the
primary get out they probably did it the
soft way first like saying look you know
here's the internal poles and you know
we think that it's best that you just
you know seek a different office run for
mayor or something like that and he
probably said no and then they said okay
yeah yeah but they they'd say you know
what happens next you they may not have
even threatened him they might have
blindsided him that's true that's how
possible but I have to imagine like
unawares if he did something wrong and
the political machine said it's time for
you to bow out and he said no they need
only say you wrote the blog you know
exactly what we're capable of yeah and
then he can be like
okay I gu I mean would it would it be
wouldn't it be funny if like Jamal buman
was like you can't scare me your your
deep State conspiracies won't stop me
I'm going to run and do the right thing
and but like no one cares because he's
kind of a bad guy yeah I I think what's
what's his constituency like like uh the
uh specific District plus 30 okay I mean
I'm Imaging so then you'd think that it
would be reasonable he's in um he's in
Westchester County New York right and so
that's fairly wealthy from what I know
about it um I'll look up the Dem I'll
look up specifics let's uh we got to
talk about the story from the Daily
Caller let's jump to this one while we
uh look up more on uh
Bowman uh from The Daily Caller budlight
hires conservative friendly comedian
Shane Gillis in face saving move in a
wild faving move budlight is partnering
with popular comedian and original
cancellation Survivor Shane Gillis for
an unlikely brand deal both sides
announced on Instagram Gillis who who
sat Saturday Night Live fired hired and
then fired shortly after woke folks
discover jokes he made on his podcast
announced a deal on Instagram excited to
announce partnership with Bud Light
Gillis wrote the deal comes not long
after an appearance on The Joe Rogan
Experience where gillson Rogan Rogan
Bandy about whether or not Bud Light can
rehabilitate its image in the wake of
the Dyan M disaster became a joke gills
told Rogan that's tough to overcome
marketing-wise it's tough to get people
to order a Bud Light publicly you're
going to get made fun of so uh Chen
gills is a funny guy he's a not a woke
guy no I don't think he can save Bud
Light I I I mean like I don't blame him
I guess for taking the money but I still
don't see how regular people will be
anything but embarrassed ordering Bud
Light I mean it was already embarrassing
to begin
with it barely gets you drunk yeah it
wasn't that good well I mean it's a
light beer so you know what's the point
basically uh you just keep it as
survival uh survival food in Le of water
or if you're Shang you drink like 36 of
them you know a little bit of a
different situation I think that's one
of the only reason he would accept it
too is because he had like a past
drinking them in I don't know you'll get
slightly Tipsy after 36 of them yeah but
uh uh here's the thing though the parent
company uh owns a lot more than just
Budweiser and Bud Light and stuff that
like that so they don't really care I
mean they lose a little bit of money but
then they can also sort of cater it to
the woke people so that you have your
specific like lgbtq plus Ma woke Dei
beer and then all your other brands like
nobody even realizes the same company as
the parent company necessarily cuz
people don't even look into that sort of
thing 99% of the time so they're still
making money that I I think that's fine
you know I'm not a big fan of the hyper
consolidation of massive
corporations so Bud Lights on the verge
of death this is this is this is the
just pure desperation there is a
potentially going to be a strike uh Bud
Light bottling plant workers say they
want to make more money budik can't pay
them more money and eer Bush can't pay
their sales are down something like $30
billion how are they going to pay more
do you guys see that story people are
posting it's a meme where it's like UPS
drivers demand better pay win and the
next one is 12,000 UPS drivers laid off
you know over like and it's just like
what do you think was going to happen
the money's got to come from somewhere
these people don't get it like you work
for a company you say hey as 100
employees we all deserve to make instead
of you know 10 bucks an hour 15 they go
okay fire a third of the staff and then
the money from them goes to you yeah
Shane Gillis is being brought on in an
act of absolute desperation if this
strike happens it could be it could be
the the end of Bud Light because all of
a sudden there's going to be a massive
shortage of a beer already nobody wants
or it could be normalizing the market
nobody wanted to buy it in the first
place but it could be Cascade failure
not enough beer is made they struggle to
sell it as it is what little product
they they make doesn't sell they don't
make back enough money to make more and
they can produce less and less and less
as more and more people quit because
they can't get paid to do the job and
then Bud light's gone by June it's part
of their Master uh plan they're going to
Rebrand as a micro
Brewery yes artificially limit the
supply double the price you know it
could work look that you should get on
their marketing board they should offer
you a job only KS or something oh yeah
it also makes me wonder who aged who
else did they approach for this position
like not maybe he was their first choice
nothing against him but were there other
you know spicy cons who were like no I
won't touch it they're like H Don junr
is not much of a drinker
and Ted junen quit it in the 80s so
would you take a sponsorship from Bud
Light Sticks no you wouldn't not for any
amount no a billion dollars all the butt
light you could drink in the world I
don't I don't drink beer now the
challenge is always this right it's it's
like I would not sell sell out to
support a Bad Company doing bad things
the question is first is budlight the
worst offender to where it is like
jumping into the pits of hell and
working with the Devil the second
question the answer may be yes I'm not
saying it's not the next question is if
they offer you a substantial amount of
money could that action which is not the
most egregious thing in the world
promoting Bud Light resting massively
more good if it was something like you
know one of the cartels wanted you to uh
endorse their human smuggling I'd be
like yeah I understand no amount of
money is going to get you to do that but
Bud light's just a crappy company that
did a bad thing if they were to pay you
like $10 million you could say I'll take
the gig and give $9 million to insert
you know nonprofits that are working
against you know uh yeah I guess if I
could like send like is it taxfree the
10 million we're talking after taxes
okay then I give like 9 million to Gun
Owners of America uh and then make a
bigger garden and say okay and then to
make YouTube video saying okay I disavow
the company that gave me the money just
backstab them but what if they said like
look if Shane Gill said yes I mean is
anybody gonna boycott Shan Gillis no I
didn't know who he was he's a funny guy
he's he was on Saturday Night Live what
what did he do he made fun of Asians he
was eventually he was ultimately
cancelled right yeah he said something
in a a Santa bit from way back in the
past uh an Asian accent chines like I
think it was just like a he generally
generally made like an an Asian uh mimic
and it was right as he got the job on
SNL some ryer went back and found
something he did like eight years ago in
the past and I have this to say Saturday
Night Live is racist and that writer who
complained should be fired as an Asian
man myself when I heard Shane gills make
that joke it made me feel
seen and then this writer came and said
he was racist and removed him from the
show here I thought here was a man who
could try and represent me a champion
for your voice and they just took him
out that's they took him away they took
him away because they're racists wait
until all the modern woke people find
out about Mad TV back then was T bin
what was the Mrs Swan M swan oh God that
was great Bobby and she's still on
Family Guy yeah yeah it's true yeah I
did not think Mad TV was all that funny
but I got to be honest neither is SNL so
I don't know I would choose Mad TV any
day over fair I would because Stuart was
like kind of just the same thing over
and over again but at least when you
watch it you
went like yeah Will Will Sasso was the
best yeah Will sass was Elvis yeah they
Bob I mean Alex Bin's fantastic she's
Lois on Family Guy yep and she was Mrs
SW one a Chinese woman oh was like the
most crazy racist stereotype of as
Lowered Expectations yeah Lowered
Expectations uh I'm allowed to like what
Shane Gillis his joke because I am an
Asian person but none of you are because
you are all white except I'm sorry
you're oppressing me as the patriarchy
right now no uh uh uh you know Serge is
allowed to be uh to laugh as well
because on the on the on the on the
privilege hierarchy he's an
African-American so he's actually closer
to the bottom so skin color doesn't
matter I'm one I'm I'm about as Native
American as as Elizabeth Warren or a
little bit more does that count okay
okay excellent all right so
Carter and uh something from the north
that's communist that's worse up sir
we're not going to be able to laugh at
this joke I don't know what to tell you
canadi Canadian so Foreigner so that's
you get a half a point for that wait I'm
a foreigner I'm a child of immigrants
and you're a woman and I'm Canadian and
British which you know everyone at this
table has a a lot of a lot of privilege
points and we also know that according
to the W women have no agency either so
even if Han Clair laughed at the joke
it's not her fault the best part is I
have not watched Matt TV or SNL ever
consistently I don't think I've ever
seen anything from Matt TV so the whole
time you guys were talking I was just
nodding like wow so fun great to hear
men talk it was uh it was it was like
SNL wasn't live though and it came out
on the same time didn't it I don't know
I know exactly it was it was it was the
same uh company did like the Mad
Magazine which I think they they stopped
making those no no no they still make
them I'm pretty sure yeah they still oh
they returned I thought they were going
under they had like they had like a
reissue a while ago my dad my dad used
to be offend of them back in the day and
they had a reissue recently that he gave
me they made those since the 1950s they
forever they got they got investigated
by Hoover's FBI at one point because
they had a board game in there that uh
it was like how to escape the draft or
something I remember reading about this
and you were and and there was a little
thing you could clip out to mail into
the FBI and some people are crazy enough
to actually do that and so they got
investigated William M gains got called
in before the FBI at one point for
Testimony wild yeah they were both in
the same time though to answer the
question like they I think they only
started making the show in like the late
90s early 80s and then SNL had been
around since like the 70s or whatever
but then eventually Matt TV went kaput
at some point I don't know but sad with
uh with Sean Strickland you know doing
his funny bit about budlight I'm going
to I'm going to fix you I'm going to
rehabilitate you and then of course
everybody knows he was robbed at UFC I
think it was it 297 I believe it was
against dupi where he clearly won the
fight and then they uh just didn't give
it to him he was robbed uh anyway the
question now becomes are we at the point
where conservatives are like are you are
you going to cancel Shane Gillis like
the people who are saying Bud Light is
out nobody nobody should be working with
them ain't nobody boycotted UFC and
ain't nobody going to boycott Shane
Gillis so you've got to make a a
decision are you are
you against Shane Gillis now I mean you
can be I'm not saying you're not allowed
to be I'm just saying I'm not for
against him and I never really drink
beer so I can't be for against budlight
either but this is the question but this
is the point like we're upset with what
budlight did last year there are people
gleefully accepting money from them if
the issue is budlight is a dead company
that no one should support these people
are happily taking their sponsorship I
mean UFC did what was like a couple
hundred million 100 million or something
yeah definitely and now Shane how much
money you think they paid him they
probably they're probably paying him a
lot of money and I would take it too
he's like he used to be like a big bl
light Drinker before all this stuff even
happened so like that's like a great pay
so it was actually like part of his
brand at one point yeah it definitely
was yeah he's like the college frat BR I
think that's the hard thing you know
there are people you like this is part
of Bud light's strategy right they they
want to make it so you will say well I
like this person so I'll make an
exception to the point where it gets
memory hold and forgotten um attempt to
reab I think the ultimate people who pay
the price are their workers which is
what we said in the beginning that who
you know the company the Executive Suite
who makes these marketing decisions
maybe some of them got fired or like
suspended or whatever they got moved to
the background for a little bit
separated from the compan company
temporarily but ultimately when they
have to answer to their shareholders
when they don't have Revenue it's the
people who actually bottle or package
the material who pay the price we are
going to go to super chats and take your
questions so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and more importantly
if you want to hang out in the members
only uncensored show where we're going
to say un not so familyfriendly things
we'll put it that way go to
timcast.net
about how much how many we can do if
you're a member at 10 bucks for 6 months
you get a free upgrade or you sign up at
25 the reason we do that is because we
have weirdo activists and trolls who try
and come in and cause problems so we had
to have some kind of screening process
and that's how it works but uh we'd love
to see you there in the uncensored
members only portion coming up at 10
p.m. over at timcast.net
or at least that's what my mom claimed
cuz she always kept her spoon in the
coffee right i' I've watched your videos
where you stir your coffee as you're
talking and yes Clank clanking is always
fun did and did they name themselves or
did you come up with the name I didn't
come up with the term clankers other
people did that's funny that's that's
that's that's organic growth right there
James Bell says budlight is sponsoring
Shane Gillis he indeed we talked about
it I'm curious to what you guys think
the bonus holes Great Name by the way
says get them vpns fired up and help us
and sticks dominate the grifty award
Awards in our respective categories our
band is currently number two in the
groups groups category sticks is rapidly
rising in the personas category do it
for our democracy we're going for the
third year in a row of winning a grifty
you won three years in a row yeah when
are this year uh I think in March is
when when hotep and the others are doing
the griffy I have W one of them I won't
be able to appear in person but
apparently I've been nominated already
again for the subsequent year so I'm
loving it I'm going to put him on
display congratulations
thanks the bonus ho says Clank while you
have sticks at the beanie compound don't
let him leave until he agrees to go on
the culture war with that spoon stealing
leprechaun and Ian to talk about the
occult also don't look up our band the
bonus hes that would be cool uh but
you're not here this week right you're
only here short briefly yeah yeah
because we do the Friday morning show
the culture War at some point it would
be cool to talk ult stuff with you Ian
and Sheamus Sheamus is uh very Catholic
Michael nolles described him as a Shiite
wahhabi Catholic that's how you
understand how Catholic Sheamus is yeah
I definitely get a boore that'd be fun
sometime yeah we'll figure that one out
all right we will grab some more Super
chats Raymond g Stanley Jr says in
Freedom I stand otherwise known as
freedan uh well freedan means place of
Freedom that's what it literally means
and uh estan means place of or city of
whatever so we went to uh do the new
studio inspection the crew is there
building the new studio the cool thing
is the table here has no
console every every person at the new
studio will have this uh console which
has got power outlets internet cough
buttons we're putting in a a dump button
which means when someone invariably says
something about you know committing
murder or whatever we can press a button
and it just disappears from the show and
then the show will just kind of blink
for you know 10 to 15 or even 30 seconds
depending on what it's set to so that's
fun but uh holy crap it looks absolutely
incredible it's it's like basically the
bathroom's all
it's nuts I go there it's a big empty
Warehouse I come back there's wood
frames we come back today the new studio
will be done Friday yeah done Friday
doesn't mean it we'll be there uh the
the work Kitchen in the in the in the
massive building it's a gigantic 40ft
building kitchen's working already
fridge is there table's got to get set
up skate park is currently under
construction uh it's not being built
there it's built in I believe Texas and
then shipped here and then so all the
wood is cut all the bar all the metal is
is is cut the screws uh uh put together
and then they come and assemble it and
then uh beneath the IRL studio is
another Studio we're building for a
variety of shows it is going to be
absolutely amazing and we should be in
there within like a week or two which is
which is crazy we'll see maybe have to
wait we have to wait because the uh the
construction of the skate park could be
too noisy but uh I don't know man we'll
see it's looking really really really
amazing way better quality cameras
better quality lights I am very very
excited for fre dastan and then uh we
also have another building with uh Shane
Cashman studio for Tales from the
inverted world live oh yeah that's which
is it's like it's creepy looking yeah it
fits the vibe fits the VI for sure very
excited man for this for this big move
and then I don't know what's going on
with this building I have I have no idea
what to do we have 10,000 square feet a
skate park in the basement a skate park
outside and uh already half the people
have you know don't work in this
building when we are officially at the
new property I'm like what do we do with
this is like turn it into the timcast
museum have have some display cases and
stuff like that give tours it's actually
not a bad idea I don't know if we'd
actually be able to monetize that and
support the building in that you know
it's like you you might beonce has a
room in her house where she keeps all of
her Awards it's just your equivalent to
Beyonce's room of your accolades we can
finally get all your YouTube plaques
together left in exact pristine
condition have have like a museum with
some of the rooms and the skate park
obvious obvously and then have like a
backup Studio like in case anything
happens or you happen to be in the area
just to keep a backup or something like
that that is a good point uh this studio
is not going anywhere we just will be
recording at the other one but I do
think it makes sense to maintain it so
in the event power goes out internet
goes down we're facing inclement weather
or for some reason we have the we have
the option to be here and uh you know we
were talking about actually utilizing
both like Monday through Thursday we're
at freedon but Fridays we come here or
something like that I actually don't
think that makes sense because the new
face is is just Wicked awesome or or
make sort of like a new lineup sort of
thing and then have like a retro show
specifically here like with a familiar
background and everything else we could
redesign this room too because we want
to do we're planning on doing a Morning
Show with uh like young to uh adult
female conservatives mostly moms
basically we want to like we we've had a
few of the women who work here or are
friends with people on the show talk
about how there's nothing for sane women
to watch CU they like in during daytime
they're taking care of the kids and
they're getting getting the kids ready
for school or things like that the view
is like the main show and they're like
it's insane it's insane people saying
insane things and so we were like okay
well why don't we create that counter
programming for like sane women who want
to hear like the perspective of other
women and moms and stuff like that so
we're looking
for maybe we'll we'll put that here I
we'll figure it out anyway super excited
for that not to mention the skate park W
it's going to be so
amazing plus there's uh roosters we're
big fans we're we're building Neo
chicken City so uh old chicken city was
in the front of the house and it was
very small it had seven population seven
it was bulldozed and destroyed for new
chicken city which is the one currently
outside right now with like 50 residents
and once we move we're going to be
building Neo chicken City and I want to
give it like a a Neo Tokyo Vibe with
like Neon Lights how amazing would that
be you know cuz like what you chickens
yeah we already have new chicken City we
can't do new new chicken City you know
so so we got to do Neo chicken chicken
country no it's got to be like the
future for the live chicken broadcast
you'll have to have someone do like a
new wave theme that gets looped or
something like that yeah we should if
you're going to do that go all out we
got remember that do you remember that
uh Roberto Jr song I wrote yes we'll
make a we'll make like a new wave 80s
style version of that we can do that
we'll figure it out all right let's read
some
more let's go here we
are wasted bonehead says good evening
from the grave my fellow clankers
Maran Holzman with a massive Super Chat
saying finally well hey I mean that wild
sticks has an open invitation to come on
literally anytime he wants it's just
when he's here you know it's a matter of
the transit more than anything else
traveling is difficult for me is it
because we're where where based out of
it's it's more just I'm terrible with
schedules I have travel anxiety Etc I
always get insomnia before I fly or go
like anywhere Beyond Vermont I have
massive travel anxiety yep are you
you're based in Vermont mhm oh okay
Rutland rut
Vegas Vegas rut Vegas is the nickname
for Rutland we call it that because the
main road through it's just box stores
lining it for miles and miles oh wow and
so it's it's sort of like a a low rent
redneck Las
Vegas let's let's see what we got
here Zim memoru says I like you sticks
but I haven't forgot you telling your
followers to vote for Biden in the Dem
primary to beat Bernie because you
thought Biden would be easier for Trump
that was a move I disagree I I think
that there were Shenanigans in the 2020
election if I look at polls now then I
think that my decision aged like fine
wine say
love single regret you know I'm not a
fan of the the people what's it Russ
limoss operation chaos the telling
people to go vote in the other people's
primary I'm not a fan of because they're
they're doing the same thing now not
that it's going to some of them are open
primaries I mean all fair and Love and
War and those ones but I guess that's
true I guess that's true I guess just
sad naive to
think that's it's going to be any other
way uh demoralize says EJ Carroll is
allowed to spend her judgment however
she pleases why do you care how a
traumatized woman chooses to live her
life do better ha that's very funny uh
traumatized that lady so she falsely
accused Trump of raping her the courts
determined that he did not when she then
went on TV and said yes he did Trump
tried to file a suit against her and the
same judge said no because her claim is
substantially true again the jury found
Trump did not rape her they held him
liable for sexual abuse which is legally
distinct quite literally Trump did not
force this woman into a room take her
pants down and do what she described as
doing the the courts a jury ruled that
Trump can't sewer judge wouldn't let it
happen how does that make sense it
doesn't she lied she was asked if he did
said yes even though the court said he
didn't and then when Trump said that's
defamation I'm going to sue or judge was
like no you can't Trump needs to sue in
West Virginia he'd win in two
seconds the grinstein liberal
commentators have uh repeatedly said
things like but the judge thought so and
the jury agreed and like oh come on like
you like it's a fair trial right well
they're being sued for defamation right
now and I tweeted I hope that they're
sued in a conservative District where
they get uh uh they lose in a summary
judgment because then we can say oh but
the judge said so they're trying to move
venues why he hey kenin Bros why are you
trying to change the venue from Texas to
Florida just go to Texas and see what
that that good old conservative judge
has to say to you in your opinions no
they want to do it in Florida may may I
please take this opportunity to say hi
Ed I'm sure I'm sure that he's going to
see this too because you know that they
scrape the Internet for whatever they
can with political commentary just to
find something that they can uh
selectively edit well they're they're uh
upset because I call them evil and I
think they are and it's because I think
they're idiots I I I disagree I think
they I think to a certain degree
probably you can call them idiots but I
think to that degree we're in various
ways we're all ignorant and stupid on
various things my issue is their intent
they know like uh uh I think it was Ed
who called Charlie Kirk racist because
Charlie Kirk made a point about how
diversity hiring practices result in you
questioning a person if they're
qualified based on their race so instead
of addressing the philosophic the
philosophy and the morals of the
argument
uh I think it was he just said Charlie
Kirk is a racist and I'm like you knew
exactly what Charlie meant he does not
judge people based on race but a Dei
program would make someone do so he's
like yes I knew that he only posts these
things to to to grift to you know it's
algorithm M hijacking mostly more than
anything else I mean they I guess they
get paid for it or something any sane
person knows that if a woman comes out
and says 30 years ago you know Donald
Trump did this to me in the Bergdorf
Goodman and then when asked about it she
can't remember when she can't explain
any of the details she doesn't even know
exactly what year it happened the dress
she allegedly was wearing according to I
think the New York Times didn't even
exist at the time wasn't available her
story makes absolutely no sense there's
no evidence any sane person can realize
it's a tainted jury pool in New York
going against Donald Trump and they act
like but it was a jury of his peers like
dude we know you guys are lying that
that's why I say they're evil yeah
because
like basically right now the culture war
is this it doesn't matter what your
politics are you could be a Libertarian
you could be a socialist Jimmy door but
if you say one thing is or is not true
then you're right-wing so they call
Jimmy door right-wing because despite
his political opinions he'll say
something like these cases are clearly
Fabrications from tainted juries any any
sane person can recognize that and he's
trying to warn like Le toids more often
than not he's like hey you're you're
you're screwing yourself you might want
to change your tactics he's trying to uh
get them to actually re-evaluate the way
they do things and they just reject him
constantly I find it funny that someone
who basically sounds like Bernie Sanders
99% of the time would get labeled
right-wing same with marah the Clapper
of cheeks says Tom said the count stops
tomorrow morning Tom M Donald we gotta
buy the song tonight I don't believe
that's correct tomorrow morning no no
tomorrow's Wednesday this the the it's
it's Thursday uh uh 11:59 p.m. Friday
midnight is the is the is when they stop
right mhm we're 100% on that one yeah um
it stops Thursday at
11:59 and it's weird because I was doing
mental gymnastics on my own head trying
to make sure that was it but yeah I mean
when so when does it's like a it's
exactly one week so yes so uh Friday at
at Friday midnight which is you know am
until Thursday 11:59 59 cuz then it
becomes Friday again right and that's
when and that's when they track the next
week so from Friday at you know 12: a.m.
until Thursday 11:59 they're tracking
everything this means that next week
Tuesday uh which is what one week from
today will be the release of the
Billboard charts for uh Tom McDonald and
Ben Shapiro based on what I already know
I think they're on the H
100 but I'm willing to bet that they're
going to play games and argue that that
for this reason or otherwise they're not
going to count some numbers even though
it's through iTunes and spot and iTunes
and Amazon it would be interesting to
see if they do that because if what you
told me before the show is true there's
no way they're not going to be on the I
mean you you you look at how many hits
he's got on YouTube and it's like almost
10 and he was trending uh on YouTube
music they were number two at one point
this pretty undeniable that they were
doing well then yes I think it's like
Megan the stallion or or Nicki Minaj
they have a song stallion mean the
stallion it's like it's got 8 million
hits on Spotify but Tom's got like eight
or n million on YouTube which YouTube
music counts but they're going to argue
it's not premium and they're going to
try and disqualify the you the music
video they're going to play dirty games
yeah yeah and honestly they'll do that
for sure and uh so I just wouldn't even
try and use any streams from YouTube I
would just discount them all and but on
sales alone they should still be on
there yeah they always play games with
YouTube they they really don't want to
count it does that make YouTube mad I
feel like YouTube wouldn't like to be
discounted as like the less than no
because the streams are if you're a
paying member of YouTube premium than
you're stream you count but but still
Hannah Clair's point stands YouTube
should be upset that music videos don't
don't track properly mhm I think the
reality is this I think the companies
they they'll track it if you're Vivo
well yeah if you're an independent
artist or your Ben Shapiro they're GNA
go I mean look I I gota be honest with
you guys it's going to be as simple as
them going
hey guys uh yeah you did hit number one
but this one wasn't labeled properly so
we can't count that you know 10 million
sales that you got so you're actually
not on the list at all sorry guys that
was your fault and there's no way to
track those numbers ever again bye or
they'll do something like spell
somebody's name wrong and not correct it
they they did this to us with trash
House Records they spelled it trash
house even though I submitted it you
know everything two separate words as
opposed to one well just they didn't
have records at the end but I registered
it as trash house so then it doesn't
track next to the other well it did but
it's just a MOG you like with them about
it I didn't bother but anyway I do
believe we have until the end of
Thursday uh but based on I based on what
I've known so far I actually think based
on there's a wide range of numbers that
we're looking at because if you go to
YouTube If you go to Spotify and you
look at their current numbers there is a
strong possibility if every everybody
listening right now bought facts by Tom
McDonald featuring Ben Shapiro they
could hit number one I'll say this if
every single person listening right now
we have 50,000 did buy the song Not only
would you be helping support Tom
McDonald because he gets that money he
can use towards doing more making more
music I'm pretty sure 50,000 sales would
put them uh uh like up to like number 40
at least 30 with the numbers they
already have it is entirely possible
that with everybody listening here
Tom McDonald's audience and the daily wi
are all pushing Ben they they could hit
number one it's it's it's an exponential
growth curve it's hard to hit but uh
based on the research we've
done there was one song that I know of
without mentioning the artist that
reached like number 60 with 60,000 sales
so I was talking the guys like we sold
about you know 50 to 60,000 and then I
checked his 100 charts and it was like
number 65 or something like that and I'm
like okay it gives gives you a general
idea of what you need to reach those
those and also once you're on the Hot
100 you don't have to hit like they say
look I'm looking at Jack harlo it's like
week weeks on chart 11 you don't have to
stay number one for 11 consecutive weeks
like you can drop and then so if if Tom
McDonald bench Pio get up there they'll
be on the Hot 100 for quite some time I
think I think it's fair to say though
this is their week after this week this
song's never coming back must this week
but after that it is cumulative yeah
that's interesting yep so uh I already
bought uh the song I recommend everybody
buy it and uh at the very least it's
it's great support for a guy who's
worked really really hard for a long
time with a really great message Tom
McDonald I'm glad that he collabed with
Ben Shapiro to boost his message his
profile as well because uh Tom should be
he he should he should be winning these
Awards he should be winning Grammys but
they they they ice people out if you
look part of the song The the chorus of
facts is how he they make music and they
push a message that's not teaching your
kids to to be thugs and your daughter to
be host it's literally what he says yet
you look at Lil Nas X and it's like be a
Satanist and and be gay and things like
that they're not going to let they're
going to try everything in their power
to stop like the industry the music
industry someone like Tom McDonald from
rising in the ranks with a positive
message of work hard be responsible for
yourself so weird they want they want to
burn it down man they want burn get
it sad that's what they've done with rap
in general it's like originally like in
the 80s a lot of the uh rap music was
like yeah hey our commun is falling
apart and we need to you know stop
smoking crack and stuff like that and
now it's hey uh I sell crack for a
living yep that's a A's robot says good
evening sticks Tim fellow clankers for
those that don't know I'm saving classic
Sci-fi anime culture with my museum The
bellata Collection located in Ponte uh
Vedra Beach Florida consider visiting
and supporting Tim reach out I may
advertise that's all that's about all
peace out right on I appreciate it we'll
take a look a is pretty cool yeah I'm a
big anime anime fan I just started
watching that I think it's a new show
solo leveling you guys don't watch anime
fun show I show no it's got four
episodes on crunchy roll anyway and uh
all conservatives who rag on uh anime
are completely wrong Michael malice is
completely wrong there's a reason why
the American comic book industry is
struggling why Eric jly is succeeding so
so massively we've talked about it with
him and why uh American kids like
Japanese Manga and Anime better the
shows that are popular in Japan are way
more about perseverance meritocracy and
giving everything you have to be the
best and then you get these woke movies
and shows in America where it's like
Captain Marvel she had the power the
whole time but the man was keeping her
down so squishy that's funny to think
about even the Pokemon theme song want
to be the very best yeah yeah that's how
it used to be can't play that to kids
these days used to be like you have to
work hard until your your your bones
break just to to you know to be the best
you can't just yeah or like Goku every
episode and eat like a ton of food every
single time you have you have to work
hard to enslave these monsters to attack
one another who who don't make Pokemon
political you're crazy I I I was a fan
of Pokemon but at this point I've been
out of the loop for so long like I have
no clue at this point I'm like I used to
be able to name them all and now it's
like I don't even know how many Pokemon
there are like
500 my brother made this joke where he
was like is there a Pokemon game that
gets rid of most of the Pokemon but
keeps the
dogs so like imagine if someone modded
Pokemon the only Pokemon in it was
Growlithe so it's
basically yeah uhhuh that's that's what
I always thought was funny about Pokemon
it's just like well vulpa as a fox foxes
are canons yeah it's just dog fighting
yeah all right here we go let's grab
some more Super
chats Dave says Clank enough said well
okay I I got to be honest there's like a
thousand doll in super chats of people
saying Clank a lot of
them all right do you sell like
signature spoons or something people
like I've actually got some here for
everyone from from pumpkin fire crafts
oh you had Bill song too didn't you Yes
actually we should grab that before we
wrap up and go to only no
here billong that's the wagu US wagu it
looks good yeah uh so did you know that
I just eat tons of bong during the
members only show is it no actually I
had no clue but uh this South African
guy over here he's bong right now I'm
pretty sure and then and then I and then
one day I I I was like I'll try
something I was like this is good and he
told me it was bong it's South African
you know dried meat yeah Anton's in
Rowan o land ofil ton.com he is uh he
can hook you up with the uh with the
good meat that's so funny he shipped me
all of the Bison Angus and you said your
spoons are locally made too or made it
made those are made by pumpkin fire
crafts it's an eBay store and uh they're
engraved so all of yall have those and
some mugs from Anton's and
the show and broughts how fun here we go
Ian Slater says beware of Sheamus
stealing TL off the show well it was
funny because everyone's posting spoons
and people post spoons for Sheamus so
that's why Hannah Clair was like oh is
it a Sheamus thing that's why I think
it'd be funny if you you know Freedom
Tunes obviously I'd imagine right yes of
course too bad Sheamus is this Irish guy
who lurks around sometimes well Sheamus
should be back soon he's actually I
think in a couple weeks he'll be back
here he says that then he steals all the
spoons and never comes back no I'm just
kidding I don't know what happened with
Ian down right now yeah it is funny that
Sheamus makes these jokes about himself
and then we all laugh and say wow
Sheamus you're so funny and then he goes
you're being racist making Irish jokes
and things set this up for traps that's
right horrible yeah all the time let's
grab some more Super
chats all right Brian says thank you for
the morning video sticks I'm a longtime
viewer was just in Vermont for the snow
grabbed a few MREs how is Vermont is it
very blue uh it's very cold at the
moment yeah H yeah no there's snow
everywhere it actually snowed uh before
we left uh it was uh pretty messy on the
road on the way to the airport oh wow
yeah it's so like here it's uh to my uh
standards this is warm the weather that
the window's open it's 36 yeah no that's
warm for a for this time of year we were
I was just in uh we were in De Moine and
it was minus 13 I think oh we came back
here and I'm like went to Alaska it was
minus 30 minus 28 and uh within a few
minutes your facial hair is covered in
icicles because you're breathing out the
moisture just collects and then your
your your eyebrows and your eyelashes
it's fun and you can see the aora
Borealis let's go dos ruse says watch
Shane's story of the Down syndrome in
Thailand meeting lady boys and you will
know I mean what does that say like that
Bud Light is sponsoring a guy who says
those things do we just accept it and
say please sponsor more of these people
just keep doing it keep giving you know
what actually I think it's fair to say
the boycott does not end budl you must
give more comedians more money and you
need to go 100 times harder in anti-woke
comedy yeah I
agree all right we'll grab some more
what do we got angry Chris has DeSantis
AG thoughts maybe I think Dan santis may
have really soured his opportunity with
the Trump Administration by the the the
way he played it but maybe they're able
to separate you know the DeSantis on the
campaign from DeSantis as the potential
AG I mean he does have a career behind
him before he ran for president there
was a time they had a friendly
relationship yeah and and and in
politics you know they insult each other
anyway because they're trying to win so
a lot of it is a little bit of political
theater more than anything else I can
see it possible I don't know if
AG uh yeah but probably a cabinet role
or an advisory position or something I I
did love Trump's statement after V
dropped out he's like I didn't like him
before but we like him now it's amazing
how you could like somebody after they
you know you know they drop out out it
was funny yeah that good dude all right
where we at we got a couple more Super
chats here we got a couple more Super
chats Trump's tweets or his truth social
posts whatever they're called always
make me laugh because the just looking
at them you can it's like you can hear
his voice he he had one today after
Illinois said you know we're going to
leave him on the ballot it has to be
something the courts decide uh and he
was like I can't remember what it was
but he was like this is your opportunity
to reelect the very best president and
that's parenthesis me exclamation point
like they just see like exactly you know
an aid isn't writing them which is not
true for most politicians and that's why
he said cifi because he like sausag
fingers the phone and then accidentally
hit send yeah and then when everyone's
like what is this he was like no one no
one will ever figure out like he I won't
you just imagine that one of the most
iconic political memes of all time was
probably just Donald Trump sitting there
on the bathroom know so great all right
uh kosim says Dana White explained that
anheiser bush is a massive contributor
to our military and other American
Charities one mistake with Dylan BS does
not outweigh that actions speak louder
than words I mean that was my point it's
not just about should we accept their
apology or pseudo apology it's not a
real apology it's when do you declare
victory over your opponents and my
position is if this is the best we get
out of Bud Light with UFC with Shane
Gillis now that's pretty good and uh I
mean Shane Gillis is massive it's like
the opposite of Dylan mulany literally
then you quite literally post videos of
Shane Gillis saying all of this
anti-walk comedy and offensive humor and
say hashtag Bud Light thank you bud
light and rub it in the woke left's face
that they are losing control of these
institutions by all means don't buy the
Bud Light but at least rub it in their
face their slogan should be rebranded
Bud Light the home of the hard
R all right I'm telling you you have to
get a marketing job with them this is
great stuff all right just imagine how
much they would sell and they take out
an ad slot on forchan
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net audience ask our guest some
questions so make sure you do that you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me personally everywhere
follow me on X at timcast sticks do you
want to shout anything out yeah at Stix
666 official on Twitter or you can find
me at Stix hexenhammer 666 on pretty
much any platform right on sweet yep um
pleasure having you man uh this has been
a lot of fun um Carter Banks you can
follow me at I still call it Twitter at
Carter Banks and and uh yeah follow
trash house records and timcast songs we
have a new song coming out soon we do I
need to talk to you after this uh me and
Jessica working on some artwork for it
I'll run your eyes over it but yeah
we're on a whole album so diving back
into the mix of several songs Hannah
clear hey well it's been fun having all
of you here uh I'm Hannah Clair rmo I'm
a writer for cnr.com that's scanner news
you can follow all of our work on uh
Instagram and Twitter at timcast news um
if you want to follow me personally I'm
on Instagram at handcar. B and I'm on uh
Twitter at HC Bremo it's been super fun
thanks everybody who's listening and
serge is here yes uh thanks for coming
sticks appreciate it uh it's been a long
time coming and I've been watching you
for a long time now too so thanks man
appreciate it nice uh I am surge.com I'm
on the internet I'm excited for the
after show let's get to it Tim we will
see all of you over at timcast.net